you
trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
[Music]
bathrooms
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
the big massive dumpster
the elements of bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of
look at that look at that that is
why who thinks he's smarter than you why
who thinks he's smarter than you why is
he smarter than you
[Music]
look at that
look at that look at that
[Music]
[Music]
that might come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake callers jones
[Music]
[Music]
tyranny look at that
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship d banking
arrest tyranny look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser and he's a
disgrace and he's just christ
and he's a disgrace and he's with his
christ
[Music]
mangoes my bags are mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
[Music]
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes manga aren't mangoes like
three boxes
that's it
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
personally affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy daughter won't need
well what an incredible day
uh a continued tragedy in the united
states of america
but uh a momentous day as well um maybe
unexpectedly or maybe exactly as
expected
it is absolute and complete protest
chaos outside the national rifle
association convention in houston texas
the site where uh former president
failed former president donald trump
will shortly be speaking we are
reviewing coverage previously aired by
right side broadcasting network
at the protests there were scuffles and
kerfuffles there were
some light fisticuffs i guess i would
say
uh but it is complete and total chaos as
multiple key republicans have actually
pulled out of speaking at the event but
trump insists this is a very
special time an in no sorry an
interesting time to speak
where was this
uh i had it somewhere
oh okay no we'll get that anyway so um
greg abbott and dan patrick have decided
they are not going to be speaking at the
nra
um however
trump and apparently ted cruz are still
expected to speak and we are monitoring
a number of different feeds we've got
right side broadcasting which is there i
guess they're getting set up indoors
right now
um unclear how many doors there are at
the convention but some such number they
are getting set up indoors this is
coverage from earlier there are protests
outside
the convention that are taking place
which we are watching
there are uh also
um cameras at a houston leadership event
on gun violence in uvalde texas the site
of that horrible mass shooting just days
ago
and at the houston rally we also are
standing by governor greg abbott from
texas is going to give some kind of a
press conference where maybe some
answers will be given about
what exactly were police doing there are
reports i'm going to tell you there were
reports of the following things and
we'll see which of these things are true
that police were too scared to go in and
confront the gunman
that police
got their own kids out of the school and
then just waited outside
all sorts of claims are being made i am
not yet ready to kind of hang my hat on
any particular claim
other than the following one
something
was not done correctly
in terms of the good guys with guns that
are always pointed to as
this is why more people should have
firearms in these situations and if
there is any greater indictment of the
ridiculous idea to arm teachers
our lunch ladies
arm janitors if there's any greater
indictment of that
than what happened with the police
in uvalde
i can't think of a greater indictment
okay and i got a bunch of emails from
teachers about a dozen and i tweeted
about this where they all say
i'm a teacher
arming me what what are you talking
about
um
it's uh i mean we we are in a very very
sad state of affairs also i'm aware that
closing arguments are happening in the
johnny depp versus amber heard
defamation trial it seems inappropriate
for today's show
i don't know what people think like yes
i'm aware it's going on but it just
doesn't seem like the right thing
to be covering today i don't know do
people agree about that
it just would seem weird
uh
yeah people are generally in agreement
yeah so we're gonna get away from that
let's listen to a little bit of the
conversations that right side had with
some of the protesters
any moment we're gonna be inside the
convention and uh a lot is happening
take a listen
here we go i'll show you my bash there
you go right there okay there you go i'm
good uh
you can just google unless you can find
out who we are
uh what's your thoughts on all this um i
don't have any thoughts they have the
right to say what they want to say i
don't i mean it's america right so just
like i agree that everybody should have
a gun they agree that nobody should have
a gun that should be left violence we
all agree on the same thing i just think
that the way of getting to is different
i don't want gun violence who wants gun
violence unless you're like a i'm sort
of crazy man i have kids too but they
all say they love their children i have
a one-year-old and nine-year-old so i
love my children also so by them saying
we love our children they're trying to
say that everybody on this side doesn't
love their children which is kind of odd
i mean
i mean i think most people love their
children
there we go for you for your good
parents out there i i mean i'm walking
around trying to engage conversation
trying to get both sides of the coin i
want to hear and i get a lot of
screaming i've got to be honest with you
i don't get a lot of logic coming from
this side at all
when i ask people about gun violence and
what to do to stop it no one says
anything no one says put more money into
communities where the problem is
happening and putting more money to the
schools well even that i mean all these
talking points as you i know you guys
i'm not i'm not blowing smoke you guys
all know this oh wait a second let me
see if i can get my super chats fixed
there there
every one of these talking points has
another side like the concept of put
money into communities that have more
crime
some of the communities that have more
crime
have it because there's more cops there
and when you have more cops they observe
more things and and there's a real
question as to well if you put the cops
in a different neighborhood
the record of crime might go up because
you've got cops looking for crime in
those neighborhoods it's this vicious
cycle you guys all know this so
there's there's no problem with trying
to stop crime obviously we all want to
stop crime but every single one of these
are sort of like straw men
distraction arguments i put out a
10-point list
of specific things i would do to stop
gun violence and it's funny because
in the segment i preface the segment by
saying
if you just pick any one item on my list
it's not going to stop all gun violence
the point here isn't well
if one thing won't solve it do nothing
that's an idiotic perspective the point
would be wow if it's such a big problem
that one thing won't stop the gun
violence then we probably should be
doing many things
uh but this is another you know talking
point they never give us a specific set
of proposals i outlined one
i outlined one and uh there was not a
ton of good faith engagement with it i
will tell you uh disappointingly um okay
we're if you're just joining us donald
trump is still planning to speak at the
nra convention momentarily
um that event is scheduled to start in
22 minutes
we are also monitoring this feed from a
protest right outside the nra convention
let's listen to what the most
conservative supreme court justice to
ever sit on the bench
justice antonin scalia are you writing
this down
no don't boo him hold on
in 2008 in dc versus heller this is
exactly what he said
like most rights
the second amendment is not unlimited
it is not a right to keep and carry any
weapon whatsoever and any manner
whatsoever and for whatever reason
so if even justice scalia can make the
point that common sense regulation does
not infringe on our rights to defend
ourselves
that we can find common ground and we
can pass the laws we need just like the
rest of the world has
unfortunately unfortunately the nra is a
very very big impediment to that we are
getting our first video from inside the
nra convention
and uh soon right side broadcasting will
be taking us inside there we're also
standing by for a press conference from
greg abbott about what the hell happened
with police in uvalde texas we will
hopefully soon get an answer to that
but there is a lot a lot happening today
and i'm really glad that you are
with us let me go to a few super chats
aaron says gun culture is the cause of
so many problems here our police are
literally in an arms race with our
citizens right there's one report that
police were like oh the shooter has an
ar-15 wow that's that's really dangerous
we're not going in there let me just
think about that
if police are saying that then maybe
that's not a firearm that should be
floating around so easily
chakaseki says proposed republican
solutions to shootings include moats
trapdoors creating an actual robocop
banning doors
prayer etc yes also banning rap music
rap music extremely dangerous oh wait
every country has rap music but they
don't have the shootings coved quote
lockdowns which texas had none of
oh wait every country had those but that
didn't cause the shoot yeah
uh no shortage of uh scapegoats
as i would um as i as i would call them
um where can you find my 10-point list
uh there's a video clip i did on my
youtube channel it's called like sp it's
like specific
let me see if i can find it
uh
so videos
here it is list of specific gun safety
regulations to try
okay
it's one of my more
more recent videos
that you can check out
okay let me say some thank yous i i
can't tell you how much i appreciate
everybody who's joining us today bob
sacamano john the elder dragon
fifth dimension
t dog queen of wildfire
brain matter
troixi
tuge
malfunction
joe sauce and jen here uh are our first
10 supporters for the stream today i
really really appreciate that
i also want to say thanks to eric
herrera who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
rory lepsky who just signed up at
joinedpakman.com numbers 11 and 12 today
and also i have two gifted memberships
kevin gouldy and juan
each gifting a membership putting us at
14. i really appreciate that other super
chats coming in
uh can we revisit defund the police now
pledge allegiance to the hip-hop
january 6th public hearings start june
9th look for trump and family to quote
travel abroad before june 9th yeah my
plan is to cover those hearings
two infants die and baby formula is
pulled from shelves across the country
19 children die and nothing is done well
they're looking very strongly at doors
darren says i'm a few miles away from
the protests in houston i'm heading over
there now all right we'll be safe darren
because it seems to be getting pretty
damn weaponized over there we don't want
uh
we certainly don't want anybody getting
hurt all right so be be very careful
pretty sure they're going through the
conference with the conference to quote
own the libs it sure ain't because of a
non-refundable deposit yes
part of this conference is oh hold on
it's better be gifted
and talented
i want you to remember
a lithia
i want jess and ryan and that family to
know
that their child
will always live with us for as long as
we live
we will pass her story and her name down
to the generations that follow us we
will never forget them we will never
forget you valde we will always remember
the second thing she asks
is that we do everything that we can
with what we have
where we are
so that no mother
ever feels as she does right now
ever has to experience the grief and the
loss that they are feeling right now at
this moment
and i say that
because there are some
including those who've lost
those who are most dear to them who will
say it is too soon
for us to talk about what we are going
to do guys you can't talk it's too soon
to talk about politics what what an
idiotic thing to say but the time for us
to have stopped vivaldi was right after
sandy hook right
the time for us
to have stopped uvaldi was right after
parkland
sure the time for us to have stopped
duvalde was right after santa fe high
school
the time for us to stop the next mass
shooting in this country is right now
right here stay with every single one of
us
yeah but they're looking very strongly
into
video games and doors
and to those everywhere
in el paso in sutherland springs in
midland odessa
in houston texas to those who've lost
somebody but because it happens so much
in this country it has numbed us and
their names never made the newspaper
they may never be remembered to those
who still live with their wounds from
gun violence disabled today not able to
live as they did the day before i want
you to know that not only are we with
you right now we are taking action at
this very moment that is on all of us to
do
is it possible maybe they could blame
critical race theory for the shooting
because that would be perfect for them
attending the nra convention across the
street
[Music]
you are not our enemies
we
are not yours
we extend our hand open
and unarmed in a gesture of peace and
fellowship to welcome you to join us to
make sure that this no longer happens in
this country
but the time for you to respond
and to join us is now
we cannot wait any longer for you
those who will be the victims of the
next mass shooting unless we act are
counting on us at this moment so please
join us now or be left behind
[Applause]
to the leadership
of the nra
and to those politicians that you have
purchased
men and women in positions of power who
care more about your power than choosing
that power to save the lives of those
that you are supposed to serve
if you have done anything good it is the
fact that you have brought us here
together and that we are committing
ourselves to act we will defeat you and
we will overcome you and we will leave
you behind well
not a bad speed
and finally
to those who are here
and to those who are watching from home
right now
we
are counting
on each other
our kids
are counting
on us
our descendants are looking back on this
moment from the future to see if we are
going to stand and fight for them or
leave them to be slaughtered we cannot
be found
wanting
there are rituals on the other side of
this
press conferences where they blame
everyone and everything but those who
are responsible for the carnage that we
see in our communities offering thoughts
and prayers but never a word of action
but let us
acknowledge that we have our own rituals
right here among us
too many
have chosen comfort
over confrontation
too many are satisfied with themselves
and those who think like them instead of
engaging with those they've never met
before who may come to a different
conclusion on this issue it is time for
us to break these rituals and to decide
what we are going to do different
because if we continue to do the same
thing yeah the thing is it's hard when
we want to deal with the guns
and they want to deal with everything
but the guns the guns they don't want to
hear a word about for those in power
and you hold office right now and who
are in the way and refuse to act please
promise me you will get in their faces
before another child is shot in their
face
me
in getting after it and going out there
and meeting the voters who will decide
the outcome of this election
in the most suppressed and voter
intimidated state in the union where so
many people have been drawn out of our
democracy we've got to be on their doors
and invite them into this next election
because the lives of our kids are
literally on the ballot
[Applause]
let us
commit ourselves right now
to doing the hardest things that we can
think of because nothing about this
will be easy we want to make sure that
no parent goes through the hardest thing
that any of us
could possibly experience what those
parents are going through and you
validity right now but also know this
action
is the antidote to despair it is the key
to victory and it is necessary if we are
ever to overcome this are you willing to
act
keep the faith
keep up the fight and let us always do
this together thank you
thank you
make way
make way make way there are too many
people on the stage oh man
you do not want to have a crush type
situation happen here there are a lot
more people than were expected at this
event and that there are there are
concerns about just crowd control not
from like a riot standpoint but just
it can get crazy can i get everybody to
step back except for the children
[Applause]
this is what we are here for do i have
your attention so here we have a rally
against gun violence and just a block
away we are now inside the nra
convention where donald trump will soon
be speaking uh the trump event scheduled
to start in 10 minutes
uh it is it is a dystopian reality in
which we find ourselves um
trump and ted cruz expected to speak and
just
completely and utterly absurd just an
insult
an insult
lily von stoop says ban gun clubs and
manufacturers from being able to lobby
or donate to all political campaigns
that's a big part of how we got here
jamila says as an architect all this one
entry talk is incredibly stupid building
codes exist a fire and one exit means
people die but the republican party will
blame the media somehow in their defense
they're talking about one unlocked entry
door with a bunch of exits with the bar
you know the bar that allows you to open
the door from the inside to exit but
it's still a problematic uh
it's still a problematic idea for a
whole bunch of other reasons which we've
talked about
i want to say thank you to tron just
call me tai and charles wieland for the
twitch prime subscriptions thank you
guys i appreciate that
also
nine memberships were just gifted on my
website from kevin combs martin
eckendall walter franco casey bates
another one from walter franco another
from walter andrew kulp
and another two
from walter which we very very much
appreciate that's nine nine plus
seventeen nine and seven is sixteen six
carry the one becomes twenty six
uh feel free to fact check me
on that math there but i think that it's
more or less
accurate
as we stand by for this
we do have a bunch of different video
from what's going on in texas let's see
if we can look at just some of it here
uh i had some elements bookmarked for us
this is video of what's going on in
front of the nra convention
people saying it it's going to be
different david hogg saying it's going
to be different
[Applause]
presumably speaking about greg abbott i
i assume
um here are
oh we already did that club okay we did
that on the show so we don't need to do
that right now let's see if i had
anything
dear god
uh
video from the event which we were just
looking at
uvalde law enforcement state they didn't
enter the classroom because they thought
it was no longer an active shooter
the
the on-scene commander at the time
believed that it had transitioned from
an active shooter to a barricaded
subject
we're well aware of that right
again you know the on-scene commander
considered a barricaded subject and that
there was time and there were no more
children at risk
obviously
obviously you know based upon the
information we have there were children
in that classroom that were at risk and
it was in fact still an active shooter
situation and not a barricaded subject
why did they have that impression i
guess is like one question i don't know
it's kind of weird
um
okay so that's the clip we just looked
at
senator ron johnson is blaming liberal
indoctrination
for the shootings but this this fellow
in texas uh salvador ramos um
he legally bought his two guns right and
now of course now we didn't have the
paper trail on the record to your point
but do you think that that would require
maybe stiffer background checks no
you know no matter what you do people
fall through the cracks you can't
identify all right but if only one out
of ten end up getting guns because you
put more obstacles in place you reduce
the shootings it's this idea that
nothing will prevent every shooting
nothing will prevent every heart attack
nothing will prevent every car accident
but that's not a reason to do nothing
these problems you can't arrest somebody
for a crime they haven't committed yet
uh these are difficult issues but again
the solution lies
in stronger families more supportive
communities i would argue renewed faith
we've we've lost
these people are
disgusting these people are truly
discussing
more faith
my god
um
let me look at a couple other super
chats
okay so this one we did
thanks to larue brown for the 50
super chat thanks for all you do david
do you think this is finally the time
something actually gets done well i hope
so
but uh
who really knows i mean i don't i'm not
trying to be pessimistic
it's just how many times have things
happened like this shooting wasn't even
as bad as sandy hook by the number of
people who died without dismissing the
fact that it's a tragedy like any other
of course it's as big of a tragedy but
by by the literal math of it more people
died at sandy hook and nothing happened
um
so i don't know i i apologize if i'm not
more optimistic
my pillow dog beds are available at half
price
with a discount code just as a kind of
fyi
um
we're continuing to monitor a number of
different feeds there's a protest
outside the nra convention
the actual event at the nra is scheduled
to start in four minutes four minutes
from now
thank you to binkles and gw jumpman for
the twitch prime subscriptions i really
appreciate that i also want to say thank
you to jason sickmeyer who just gifted a
subscription and we'll go in order
um as those as those come in we'll keep
gifting them to people if you don't yet
have a david pakman show website
membership i would love it if you
grabbed one at joinedpakman.com
take care of yourself first you can use
the coupon code obama when you type in
obama obama you'll see that the price
gets much lower okay get yourself a
membership first this is our primary
funding source but be aware that you can
use this button is this a gift to put
gifted memberships in a queue as it were
about 450 people have asked for free
membership so far and we'll give them
away one at a time as they come in okay
so i would i would love for you to take
advantage of either of those
we love it
joshua says by his reasoning we
shouldn't ban abortion because bad
people will always find ways to get them
exactly right
nothing will change david that is
america says papi
see what's going on here houston is you
know petrochemical
headquarters of the world
uh for the most part a lot of industry
here
in texas a lot of industry here in
houston and so beautiful petrochemicals
uh coming from there as you can as you
can imagine
um
couple voicemails
let's see here uh what do we have
yes i've been following all this on the
guns
and the shootings the murders
how ridiculous this really is
and they definitely need to screen
people
100
and i am a gun owner
i assume i assume the caller means a
mental health screening people that do
not deserve to own a gun
i've heard of all these solutions
how about a solution of
a gun owner
needing a co-signer
right i actually i that's
in a number of different ways i
mentioned that
uh if you're under 25
it should be even more rigorous and
there should be an adult a real adult
that is involved these are all good
ideas
um
and all ideas that the right will never
ever ever ever ever ever go for no
matter what no matter what
the guns
then uh
then everything should be okay but we
all know that uh common sense would
dictate that
you know you can take away all the guns
but the bad guys simply are not going to
give up
their guns just again it's kind of
ridiculous because every gun is legal at
some point okay so if there's just
generally fewer guns around
yes some people will obtain them
illegally but there are fewer guns
around to obtain illegally it's just a
mathematical reality
it's sort of like hey listen if we made
cars illegal you could be like people
can still figure out how to get them
right but there's just fewer cars around
to get
illegally i i i just don't understand
how they can say we don't care
they can say we don't want to make it
more difficult oh okay well now you're
actually being honest but it's just a
mathematical reality
these are lies yeah patrick says these
are lies that have been repeated for
decades they absolutely have
super chats continue coming in
remember that time ron johnson uh
celebrated the fourth of july in russia
we do i actually don't remember that
and thanks to scurry away
for the super chat very much appreciate
that i want to say thank you to gilman
triantos who just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 30 today also want to say thanks
to sarah kennedy burge
and stage presence new members 31 and 32
at joinpackman.com and also thanks to
nicholas mcmullen who just added a
gifted membership to our cue to give
away we'll do that a little bit later
lastly thanks to koiani for the twitch
prime subscription your number 34. you
haven't missed anything if you're just
joining us donald trump's event
scheduled to start any second we don't
know whether
ted cruz is speaking first greg abbott
has bailed lieutenant governor dan
patrick has bailed but president trump
as well as ted cruz are expected to
speak we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines well not against
guns that's for damn sure not against
guns a couple other things to look at
a lot of video from the protests outside
the event
um
see if we have anything else
here's protesters just yelling at people
going to the convention
[Applause]
[Music]
dear god
right-wing broadcaster tries to hit
student protesting the nra meeting with
the usual talking points and the kid
destroys him on every level oh i've got
to see this
what fifth grade sixth grade i'm in um
i'm a freshman freshman there you go
what's your thoughts on
maybe adding additional security to
schools like maybe it is i don't know if
you're like if you're a principal if you
have if you have a security person at
your school would that make you feel
safer at school
no it really doesn't like
the fact is a lot of these schools who
do have these incidents
still have shootings and students are
still afraid to go to school like this
is a place where i'm supposed to learn i
should not have to feel
like i should not have to feel like i
could get shot at any moment like i just
want to be safe in my learning
environment true you have a security
office or your school that you're at
right now
we have an unarmed peace officer
but do you think that statistically if
he was armed and someone was coming your
school that he'd be able to take him out
before he was a cult harm in your school
no
you don't think that a good guy with a
gun would be able to stop a bad guy with
a gun no
we just need no people with guns people
but
it's going to be virtually impossible to
do that so we got to come up with a
different solution do you expect people
with guns to turn in their guns
i think if you need guns like he there
just needs to be more background
checking their needs like i don't think
someone needs military grade like
weapons like people should not have
semi-automatic guns like
so you want to clean up the type of gun
that's on the street and then make it
harder to get one yeah
there you go thanks for your time
god
oh my god uh i'm gonna i'm gonna work
fifth grade sixth grade i'm gonna
bookmark that i might use that next week
um man what what a country what a
country guys i mean this this is just
unbelievable
uh let's see if we've got anything else
to look at from there
uh
we looked at that clip
defending the police
we looked at the ron johnson clip
already
i don't even want to deal with that
what efforts were the officers making to
try to break through the door or another
door to get in none huh we just need you
to stay at the microphone because
otherwise the camera's gone thank you
for doing this and i do hope you stay
here and take as many questions oh this
is shimon procopes he's been asking good
questions as possible you say there were
19 officers gathered in the hallway or
somewhere what efforts were made to try
and break through that door you say it
was locked
what efforts were the officers making to
try and break through either that door
or another door to get inside that
classroom none at that time
the
the on-scene commander at the time
believed that it had transitioned oh
okay so that's the clip we looked at
before yeah
um
oh and i guess he says it was not the
right decision
the question simply is this was a
40-minute gap
and if the 9-1-1 operators were aware
that that children were live in that
classroom why weren't officers notified
of that and if that's the case why
didn't they take action that's the
question and again i'll go back to the
answer for right now is that that it was
considered okay the decision was made on
the scene
i wasn't there
at the same point in time
you know a decision was made that this
is a barricaded subject
situation there was time
to retrieve the keys and wait for a
tactical team with the equipment
to go ahead and breach the door but and
take on the subject at that point that
was the decision that was the thought
process that particular point in time
[Applause]
[Music]
like i said there was 19 officers in
there in fact there was plenty of
officers to do whatever needed to be
done with one exception is that the
the incident commander inside believed
they needed more equipment
and more officers to do a tactical
breach at that point that's why vortac
was requested on the scene as soon as
they were there they executed they
searched i released a dynamic entry and
went in and uh of course that was not
until 12th that was not the question
hey
hey
hey with the benefit of today for the
benefit of hindsight hey the benefit of
hey stand by and stand by hey stand by
hey stand by all right i got it okay i
got it okay hey from the for the benefit
of hindsight where i'm sitting now then
of course it was not the right decision
it was a wrong decision period there's
no no excuse for that
but again i wasn't there but i'm just
telling you from what we know
we believe there should have been an
entry at that as soon as you can man
there will probably be you know some
investigation somebody will get fired or
maybe not even they'll get disciplined
but it's like it's it's obviously too
late that you know the tragedy has taken
place it's
it's just
all unbelievable you know with all these
things that are just not functioning
correctly including how easy it is to
get guns and the fact that the police
hung out for 40 to 60 minutes all these
things they're like
arming teachers is the way to fix this
problem it's it's so disturbing
um yeah maybe the guy who made the
decision will get a paid suspension
pending the investigation it's it's
insane it's absolutely insane what's
going on
thanks to david stanek david just signed
up on my website at joinedpakman.com and
his new member number 35 also want to
say thank you to some people gifting
subscriptions including jason sickmeyer
stage presence jason sickmeyer with two
more three more four more
uh very much appreciate that that's
six gifted memberships putting us at 41.
really appreciate that guys we're
standing by here uh for the nra event
there are also protests outside let's
briefly listening listen into what's
happening there
it is mainly
latino families
oh i'm sorry
[Music]
i spent my whole child in teen hood
there i graduated high school in that
community
and it is a
very like i know everybody always says
how could this happen in my town or my
environment and i truthfully asked that
when it happened i was absolutely
speechless i've been an advocate for gun
control since i was 12 and i'm now 22.
and
i'm just asking
for all of you
to really have those hard conversations
with your friends and family and your
neighbors and your classmates i know
it's uncomfortable i know talking about
gun control of people whose first
responses we should arm teachers and
that you're crazy for thinking that is
really difficult but i am begging for my
community my
my
cousin's wife lost
a family member in this shooting
so i'm asking for all of you to please
please put yourself in those
uncomfortable positions to talk to
people to make a difference to make a
change
sign up so vote i see there's a lot of
people here trying to get you guys to
register
i just want people to know that that
small town even though it was small
it's full of all of my first it's where
i grew up
and i
[Applause]
we deserve better everyone deserves
better your kids your teachers my mom is
a teacher she taught the isd
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm just thankful to see all of you and
i'm grateful and i just wanted people to
know that that community because i i
would although it was small
was kind and it was sweet and it's full
of a lot of people's memories and my
whole hometown is healing and grieving
and even though i no longer live there
and i am
trying my absolute best to spread
awareness please spread gofundme they're
all over social media
share facebook links of those families
of those kids
and be present take care of each other
and that's all i wanted to say thank all
of you for coming
so this is the rally across the street
from the nra convention here's the nra
convention and it is about to start
where donald trump will speak and
presumably talk about how great guns are
and how important it is that we not make
it at all more difficult for anybody to
get a gun that's
what we're expecting and yes a lot of
people
have indeed had enough of this
crap for sure
um
man
this is uh yeah they're 10 minutes late
this is scheduled to start any second we
we're just standing by scheduled to
start any second
cody says i bet they would arm the
teachers and not even think about a pay
increase since we're being ridiculous
let's get all the kids body armor newt
gingrich said give the teachers who want
to be armed 500 bucks a month
that was newt gingrich's idea quite an
idea huh
thanks to yarn inquiries and decomposing
diva for the twitch prime subscriptions
you are numbers 42
and 43.
i do plan to be live tomorrow with the
wyoming rally in the afternoon uh unless
something changes but i do i do plan to
be live with that um and this program
that's about to start here i believe
will feature
failed former president donald trump
republican senator ted cruz
and i think the nra's wayne lapierre uh
really a competition between those three
for who is the absolute most disgusting
one of the three it's kind of hard to
say they're all bad they're all very
very bad
uh i want to say thank you to brian
edwards brian just signed up on my
website joinpacman.com and his new
member number 44. also thanks to ryan
biela who just purchased a gifted
subscription which we will give away
there's only we're down to about 400
people
waiting for free membership so this is a
good time to put your name on the list
davidpakman.com free membership if you
would like
and uh in all seriousness i would love
for you to sign up at joinpackman.com
and get a membership it is our our
primary
funding source and i'm not going to
offer you discounted pillows the way
they're doing on right side broadcasting
we we just we do an extra show every day
and we offer the show commercial free
six hours earlier to people who sign up
on our website that's those are the
things we offer okay i'm not gonna send
any pillows i'm not gonna send you a dog
pillow i'm not gonna send you a foot
pillow or anything like that
uh but you can sign up we have this
coupon code you can use obama obama
you'll get a discount everybody's free
to use it and it is our primary funding
source right now we're unfortunately
limited on instagram for spreading covet
disinformation if you can believe it
instagram has misidentified our content
debunking covet disinformation as us
spreading covet disinformation so we are
now gifted uh we are now limited there
speaking of gifts purple poundini
has just gifted
50 subscriptions via twitch
puts us at 95 and purple signed up for
themselves putting us at 96. that's 50
with a v
that's 50 with a v as in victor
if you can imagine that which is bonkers
it's absolutely bonkers and we will ban
men right
um some other super chats coming in oh
and thanks to our friend lars from
deeper shades of house for gifting five
putting us at 101
super chats are dumping in at people
feeling very strongly
uh oh now it says trump will speak at 5
30 eastern okay well we may pause then
at a certain point uh devin this country
is disgusting how do you not get
consumed by anger having to watch this
for a living every day david i have no
faith left in this country how much
pressure is needed for change clearly
there hasn't been enough
clearly there hasn't been enough
trump would have charged the room with
the shooter right he wouldn't have
waited outside for an hour well you're
joking trump literally said after the
florida school shooting i would have run
in there unarmed
i would have run in there unarmed trump
said
a border wall won't stop illegal
immigration so we shouldn't try to
regulate immigration right yes same
logic tom
same logic it's it's exactly the
argument that they're making
i mean uh it's yeah for sure
um
okay
let's listen to what's going on hello
uh the media was real quick
really quick to label that whole white
supremacist thing and it was them and
that the african
american community was was targeted uh
for that and and ends up that that was
the facts
but a lot of times they roll the dice on
this stuff because they have a narrative
they would like for to be pushed out and
i think they kind of got
a little lucky on that because we didn't
know much uh at all about the shooter at
the time oh my god but what what bizarre
analysis
um
[Music]
sick when our prisons are safer than our
schools says michael d yeah that is uh
in some in some cases
that is true
uh it's quite sickening thanks to doug
griffith for signing up on my website as
well as lori marie cevello both using
the coupon code obama
new members 102 and 103.
also thanks to simon reed for gifting a
subscription that's number 104
couple voicemails about what's going on
let's take a listen to
some of them here's juan with an idea
hey david it's juan here
uh about the gun violence and
the gun issue
there are two ways to motivate people
okay motivate people with things they
want and you motivate people with things
they don't want
how about
one million dollar
fine
for every bullet you shoot
against an innocent person
do you want to have guns fine yeah
uh republicans aren't going to go for
that unfortunately they will never ever
ever ever go for that
hi david this is cliff in seattle um
watching your stream right now about the
nra convention
and a couple of things that popped mine
that i haven't really seen talked about
yet uh first is the
race of the situation um most of the uh
children that were killed in this
tragedy were hispanic including and so
was the uh perpetrator
and um
i am just curious how much all of our
invasion talks all of the talk how
mexico sends us
rapists and murderers how much that
plays into
um
possibly the motivation of the killer
even though this is a
hispanic man he uh
it's not uncommon for
this sort of rhetoric to spur on uh
self-hatred in
these same groups
another quick question i had for you was
if we are to truly believe that um
gun ownership shouldn't be restricted in
any way what to stop the likes of the
jeff bezos or an elon musk from
developing
nuclear weapons they could certainly
hire the best
and pay the best uh
scientists to develop um
weapons of mass destruction uh yeah or
you know shoulder-mounted rpgs or
whatever right i mean that's it why why
draw the line anywhere i guess i don't
know
um other super chats david if they
designate school children to be late
term post fetuses then republicans will
have no choice but tag yeah i i mean i i
didn't tweet it because it seemed a
little bit crass in the moment
but you know if you could if you could
make republicans think that a school
shooting is sort of like a really really
late term abortion
they would act immediately and it's like
sort of a joke but it's kind of true and
just a reminder of the absurdity
of circumstances currently
in the united states it's uh
it's a it's a very very sad state of
affairs
i want to say thank you to dana heaton
as well as diana lyman who have each
signed up for memberships at
joinpakman.com
also jason sickmeyer has just gifted
another membership and that's number 107
over on twitch i want to say thanks to
deep doob
who has just gotten a twitch prime
subscription which i really appreciate
as well
ryan says given supreme court thomas's
wife's efforts on january 6th do you see
the supreme court overturning the
election in 24 like was done in 2000
i'm not even thinking that far ahead yet
i'm just not even going to think that
far ahead
let's deal with one one thing at a time
but maybe yeah i mean obviously it's a
fear
david love you on your show the school
shootings remind me of my scare in
senior year of high school in 98 we had
a bomb scare that's it
right
david what compromises would you make
with the gop to pass gun reform i mean
you know they can keep
a bunch of guns legal and yeah i mean
the compromise is that there's there's
400 million guns in the country right i
mean and we've already compromised so
much that's that's the absurdity
stephen says based on how dangerous
trump says they are perhaps arming
teachers with fruits and vegetables
might work i wonder if republicans would
go for that there's an idea
look at michigan governors race and
james craig okay not right now now
we're not gonna do that exactly right
now but i'll make a note to look into
that
um okay let's see this
and this and this okay all right so the
trump speech has been pushed back to 5
30 eastern so i think what we're gonna
do is i'm gonna try to get my work done
now i'm just gonna continue the stream
we'll keep the stream on the protest
i'll just step away super chats will be
live i understand if some people step
away i'll be back in like an hour or so
and then we'll get things going again
they've delayed everything by quite
literally two and a half hours which is
just completely and utterly insane
um okay so we're gonna do that we'll get
the audio going on the protest i'll be
back and trump will ultimately speak
here we go
voting is important
running is also important
we need to run
we need our officials to look like us
thank you
ryan
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
two days ago i was at lunch and i asked
my best friend
how many math shootings have they paid
at schools since sandy hook
he said 20 25 maybe 30.
the answer is 948
948
10 years ago lawmakers told us never
again after safety hooked but they
failed
but we have to understand that school
shootings are just a tip of the iceberg
when it comes to gun violence against
kids in the youth
every single day three dollars every
single year 3 000 kids are killed
annually by firearm most of them from
suicide less than 30 percent of national
sorry less than 20 percent of mass
shootings at schools really comprise the
deaths of children
now we're here today
to
essentially we're here today to refuse
and
disband the nra we're here basically to
let the nra know that we're going to
counter the the radical views that they
espouse about gun culture in our country
gun culture has taken over texas and has
taking over our country but we're
fighting back
you know and whenever this debate comes
up whenever it comes up the nra always
says the same thing
they always say
well that's it but they always say
guns don't kill people
people do
when they say that ask them why they
don't support red flag laws that would
take guns out of the hands of those
dangerous people we're making that
active one of them support universal
background check and make sure enough
not just anybody can get it good
when they say that asking why they don't
support revealing the plcaa which is
legislation that prevents us from
litigation against gun manufacturers and
gun distributors that recklessly
distribute guns to anybody
but more importantly
ask them what they say
not to vote you know when they say not
to politicize students
afterwards their politics as preventing
any progress from happening in the first
place
and lastly and lastly
you should ask them why they call
themselves an interest group where
they'll have the interest of anyone's
safety and mine
[Music]
see as we transition out of the pandemic
we have to understand that the
underlying epidemic of gun violence has
stayed with us for decades and decades
and decades and it's going to continue
to grow on faster unless we do something
about it
after columbine we were shocked after
sandy hook we said no more after
portland we were outraged but after
you've all day nothing just happened
and right there
exactly
i need everybody to talk to and to talk
to their senator talk to ted cruz talk
to john cornyn cornyn's show he's
willing to support red flagler we need
to pressure him to make sure that he
doesn't but it's not just in texas it's
not just national it's city races and
state races businesses have to make sure
they're not supporting gun culture we
have to make sure our streets are safe
and we have to make sure that we're
asking the right questions to the right
people holding them accountable making
sure no more will ever happen all right
go away thank you everybody
if you are on the change and you are a
victim of your violence step forward
if you're on the stage and you are a
victim of gun violence step forward
i know
hello everyone
i'm not gonna do better than you ain't
that hot
hello everyone
that's what i'm talking about say his
name george kemp
say his name george kemp
you never heard of george kim but you
don't hear about it today
that's because his mother is standing
here
[Applause]
and i am in
my right mind
they say when you lose a child that you
supposed to be crazy as they are
i thought i was gonna be crazy as hell
and until i thought about my own son
so i thought about when i got that call
that my child was no longer here then
somebody could take a gun and murder my
only son my 20 year old son my hopes and
my dreams
it's gone
y'all don't understand the hell that
those parents in new valley buffalo and
the everyday citizens here in houston
are suffering and going through
this is not a show i just want you to
know
this is not a show this is real deal
if you have never
begged god for your child to bring your
child back and you've never been
you can bear to you ain't nothing coming
out your mouth
life goes on and you sing in your porch
rocking
you gotta get up and use the restroom
that's your normal body function and you
see an empty bedroom what the hell do
you do
what do you do
and every day all black children are
being murdered
do we give the attention that we need
hell no
is it right
hell no do you care hell yeah you need
to care
because just because my child did not
look like you
does not mean that you feel dangerous
matter to me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
deeply
when you get to take your children to
school they tell you make sure your
children got all they shot right
y'all know the checklist
done all that
participating with your child to make
sure that they have a productive life
every black child ain't no thug and gang
related what the hell
that is a narrative that we're not
having this [ __ ] no more
have you lost your mind
you're not gonna devalue our black
children
you're not gonna do it on our watch
but i tell you what
[Applause]
when i have to bury my only son
and my friend said oh my god that girl
she looks like she in a fall i was
but then she said y'all don't know what
i know
wait till that girl wake up it's gonna
be hell
i woke up
i woke up
i woke up and i got up
i didn't wait for nobody to come grab me
and say come on this camp i got up for
myself
i got up and started fighting and
educated by myself i got to start
organizing
i started moving because he was my child
in that damn ground it wasn't yours he
was mine
but i told my son i had to get up in
this race
because that was like youtube the sun
the elements was it had me down i was
laying on my child's grave and the sun
were burning the ants were biting my
legs was going on and i felt my son say
mama get on up
get out and go
[Applause]
so i've help on this journey for nine
years and i will never stop but what did
i do i got up i thought advocated i
started grabbing mothers and fathers
that looked like me and said you're not
gonna die if you accept your assignment
on your life and get up and get moving
you let them know that your child was
here and deserve to be here no one is
going to take my child's hopes and
dreams
in names
as long as george kim's mother shows up
they got hell to pay
[Applause]
but i'm not by myself
i'm not by myself as you can see i'm
wearing orange why are you wearing
orange i made it like a big pot a big
orange sticker i don't care
but orange is a colorful gun violence we
have worked hard and tirelessly to get
jeff 15 to recognize gun violence
but honestly it should not have taken
you
it should have taken every time you saw
it on the news that you got up and you
did something about it
[Applause]
these are real family these are real
people real families that are hurting
that do not have their children
you have to look at all this and say we
the people
then he just said wait
[Applause]
we gonna get changed
and at the end of the day everybody
holds my finger up right here
this little finger for me represents so
much
it represents you
the of one
but it also represents
when you go to the polls and you vote
you take this little finger
and you select those that hear your
cries and your pain that will do
[Applause]
all of that
and you take that from kevin's mother
but at this time say his name george
kelly
say his name
[Applause]
now at this time i'm going to turn it
over to
casper
it's not just me alone
another family right here in your local
city
you don't have to go to your value you
need to look right here in your own back
door and see what's going on
once you hear this man's story
please
get up and take action and say david
say his name
mr paul castro everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is paul castro i want to thank
black lives matter mom's command action
and the other groups who brought us
together today
[Applause]
i stand here
in sadness there are some people i
haven't met yet and i look at your faces
and i don't know you but i know your
story and i'm sorry
i'm sorry for the losses that you guys
have experienced because there's nothing
there's nothing that feels like losing a
child losing a brother
losing a sister use losing a friend this
is my daughter anastasia and this is my
son david
july 6 2021 last year my 17 year old son
david was killed
right over here
got chased this for five minutes shot
twice him in the head
the people walking through those doors
today
they're okay with that
okay
they would rather protect
people's rights to own guns the people
who killed our children
killed our brothers and our sisters
they're okay with that they want no
restrictions
no restrictions
the guy who killed my son two-time
felon why did he have a gun because it's
so damn easy to get one because we
leave our guns in our cars to protect
ourselves they get stolen and those guns
get used to kill other people
we're not taking care of the things that
matter
and so things happen and we sit there
and go oh what are we gonna do
oh it's too much
should be graduating next month
he's dead
that won't get fixed people tell me
you're going to see him in heaven
screw
that our kids should be here today with
us
today
i heard on the news that the uvalde
congressman said
oh my goodness this same guy he had a
mental illness he threatened the school
four years ago and how do you get a hold
of a gun how to get him a hold of a gun
he got a hold of a gun because those
people
don't want laws called red flag laws
where someone could pick up the phone
and say hey that guy's going to go do
something bad stop him
he has the right to do something bad we
have the right to stop him after he does
the thing back after he causes more of
us to be up here
and they can go to hell
when mr gonzalez look in the mirror and
change your vote
and he voted against anything
restricting gun use
that's not okay
represent yourselves represent us and do
what's right
and for all the cosplay guys over there
who go around wearing
uh camouflage being tough guys
not a damn one of them would have gone
into the building when the shooting was
happening
not a damn one
so the whole
good guy who's done stop bad guys who's
gone that's a load of crap
[Music]
keep the guns out of the bad guy's hands
if that guy would have come after me
with a knife i would have driven a
little bit faster that night
okay that's dark humor i get to do that
that's my son
but that guy could not have caught us
with a damn knife
he took a shot
and this guy who was in prison for 13
years and out for nine months before
shooting at us that guy
got a lucky shot hit my son in the back
of the head i had to hold his head
driving because he chased us for three
more minutes trying to find us and kill
my other son
kill me
because guns are so damn easy to get
he had mismatched bullets
because bullets are everywhere
that's on us
and so all y'all who are out here you
need to go out and get people registered
to vote
people in austin want to make it harder
that's fine no we're out here in the sun
for two freaking hours
get 10 people signed up to vote
and let's change things
we don't want any more company up here
if we have the same thing i'm sure we
want to be the last people up here
and i'm sorry i am sorry i am sorry that
y'all are here i'm sorry to be here i
hell i don't want to be i want to be
getting my son ready for graduation
going to college
but instead his friends had to remember
him and they're so freaking used to
death
that they kind of know how to do this
they're like
like that's wrong okay that's not okay
so i'm speaking out to my friends who
have guns i have a lot of friends with
guns i have two friends who have ar-15s
and i grew up in a gun culture i grew up
i know how to shoot i i know guns
i don't have a problem with guns i have
a problem with bad people having guns
but i have a definite problem
with ar-15s
i have a
definite problem with weapons of mass
killing that have no reason for
existence so i'm going to tell you my
friends who have guns
is time to consider
okay
and at a minimum at a minimum
you should be picking up the phone
calling your congressman and saying hey
i'm a gun owner and
i used to be a member of the nra i threw
up my membership card i'm not a part of
that anymore
and i'm calling on you my friends who
are republicans
to join those of us who are looking for
a solution but i'm also not letting my
democratic friends off the hook because
y'all ain't doing enough either
okay
we need both sides to come together
because in texas we demand better we
deserve better and for all the sad
posters i'm seeing of friends of people
who died i'm sorry my heart is broken
for you but i'm going to tell you right
now
if the people we have in charge don't
get this fixed after this
we're going to vote them out thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
no one should have to go through what
his family has gone through and he
picked up the mic almost immediately and
started talking to all of us about what
we need to change and that takes courage
so much courage i want to let you know
that we have sprinklers going off over
here to my right if you are hot go cool
off in the sprinklers there's also some
water features in the park back over
here you can go cool off over there
and we are wrapping up soon but there
are still some very important voices if
you are here
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is tiffany lee
and i'm here on behalf of the fan of
the family of jalen randle
if you have a poster please hold it up
i'm sorry y'all we've been watching
since this morning
i'm just trying to gain the strength and
wisdom to gather the words
just to make this short dana rather was
killed by houston police a month ago
from today
police chased him before the cop got out
of the car he stated he's not going to
live or leave this neighborhood alive if
i'm not mistaken those was his exact
words meaning it was pre-meditated
murder this same officer he jumped out
the car and shot jalen in the back of
his neck
in a matter of three seconds in a matter
of three seconds he jumped out of the
car and shot jalen in the back of his
deck jaden was running from him
obviously he was shot in the back of his
neck he then ran upon him hog title guys
when i say hotel i'm not exaggerating
i'm going to ask you to pull out your
phones so that you can pull it up on
youtube and you can see the body cam
yourself so please don't take my word
for it i'm just giving you a description
of what happened he after he shot him he
hulk title
he searched his pockets then he
then he dragged him for three feet
once he drank him for three feet they
then said one office this office i'm
sorry y'all the same officer did this
he's the same one that shot them the
same way that handcuffed them the same
one
they dragged them
uh
after that was done
one officer then asked was he strike
where is he shot they then tossed him
over then they seen that he was striking
the back of the net they then stated we
cannot move them they said we cannot
move them after they shot them after
they handcuffed them tossed them around
and dragged him three feet who's the
same they didn't kill him then if that
makes sense i said everybody pull out
your phones
i will give you time
i want you to go to youtube
i ask that everyone pull out your phones
and go to youtube
type in hpd
critical incident incidents
hpd
houston police department hpv
critical incident
4
27
20 22 at
8700 jose street i'm going to repeat it
one more time hpd
critical incident
427
2022
at 8700 josie street now when you pull
it up you're going to see snippets uh
one of the symphonies is when the
newscast used i want everyone to look at
the 10 minute 30 seconds i believe video
is the very first video it shows the
body cam of each and every obstacle that
was involved
okay please do not just look at the
two-minute or the three-man because he
does not give you the full story look at
the ten minute one okay
i'm sorry y'all justice for tayden one
time please
one more time justice for jaylen
if you guys can watch with us or come
with us in front of him
office next not this monday but next
monday at noon we definitely need the
support please
[Applause]
[Music]
she said when
when you meet
when you meet
when we make this stain in front of him
all's office
when
not if
when remember when i said we will hold
your candidate hostage we wasn't joking
black women are tired of playing with
you so what she said was win
and i'm gonna give her this mic back so
she can tell you when you will show up
for black lives cause black lives have
always showed up for you
[Applause]
[Music]
not this monday but next monday we will
be in front of kim all's office 500
jefferson but just to add a little bit
a lot of newscasts keep asking us what
do we want to do to honor jayden
brownlee
my personal opinion i think we need to
build habitat around the law create a
jail around a bill that would protect us
citizens against the police meaning if a
police is uh
let's say you shot someone and it's not
somebody they should automatically go to
jail and be held just like us
i mean
why don't we have to wait we gotta we
have the family has to wait for our body
cam we had to wait for so much wow if we
want to shout and change police officer
from behind
and then handcuffed them searched them
tossed them around and then dragged them
y'all please look at that video don't
take my word for it i know it's hot
y'all be like all day we've been out
here all day when you get a chance
please look at that video if you don't
do nothing else after you do it you have
social media please post justice for
jayla this just happened last month
just last month the mayor having reached
out to the family
the police chief had to reach out to the
family the district attorney had to
reach out to nobody so please it takes
us
it takes us thank you
thank you
all right i need all of our elected
officials to please come to the front of
the stage we're going to be wrapping up
probably at three the bike is getting
cut at three so we are very close uh one
one of our elected officials is going to
speak on behalf of all the officials
that were not able to have time to speak
today and that's abby kavan who has
helped us organize today and i'm going
to pass her the mic
all right i know we're tired but we are
not tired
[Applause]
my name is abby cayman i am one of your
city council members but here with me we
have state represent here i'm going to
let you all go down the line and
introduce yourselves real quick
[Applause]
i'm going to say this really quickly i
was supposed to speak as a victim of gun
violence so i'm going to tell you about
my the people in my family that have
died my brother
true boy megan jones was murdered
may 31st 1996.
and i'm elected just so you know
maya donald k
murdered in 1984
when i was in high school
my cousin roderick
was murdered when i was on city council
so gun violence affects everybody and i
have about 12 more family members that
were murdered
i want to say this to you
i'm the sister of somebody who was shot
five times twice in the head
as devastated as i still am to this day
because my brother had no children
so his bloodline died
my mother has not been the same
so i want for you guys to think about
when
christmas comes when your loved one's
birthday comes
when holidays coming everybody's there
and not they're not there
my mother cries all the time
my mother is terrified that my other
brother is going to get
murdered likey mecca
i hear people saying
that we need to talk to politicians i'm
a politician i'm a different kind of
politician but i can tell you what
politicians pay attention to
because i've heard people say
that the nra gives people a lot of money
politicians aren't going to listen to us
if we just protest
i'm going to just say at one moment
again
politicians aren't going to listen to us
if we just call their office
i'm just saying
politicians listen to rich people who
project nra their gun rights over people
politicians only listen when you go vote
i want to say this i hear you saying
give people register to vote
registering a vote isn't a vote
so
all i'm saying because like i said
you're talking about all these people in
my family i actually got shot at for the
first time
like i've been shot multiple times when
i lived in fifth ward on colleen's work
i saw my first dead body
died of a gunshot when i was four years
old outside of my grandfather's my
grandparents house
so i'm saying to you you got to do more
than protests you got to do more than
call elected officials you have got to
vote
because they don't listen
my name is joanna jones
i wear this hat this is hot
so just please you got to vote
right this isn't going to work if we
don't vote with it
[Applause]
[Music]
just like jelana said we must vote but
there are things that you can be doing
today i want everyone to pull out your
phones
and we also have christina morales i
apologize there's a lot okay
but we're gonna focus on the kids we are
focused on the family we're not focused
right now on us so i want you to pull
out your phones
if you want to work with mom's demand
and support mom's demand
text
six four four three three you're gonna
text the word act to six four four three
three
now for all of our students all of our
kids we are with you we hear you we're
about to hear from someone that is
extraordinarily resilient just like all
the other voices of our students today
just like you
if you are a student and you want to
support march for our lives
text march
to 954-954
again 954-954
and if you see someone in a red shirt
you can ask them for that text message
again
i will leave you with this
hope does not bring forth action
action brings forth hope let's get it
[Music]
done hey y'all
so i
as you can tell from the very weird
symbol
i'm a very weird person who's standing
up here today especially when you look
at the people behind me
and they're all in one color more or
less
and that's a problem
my name is carly walter and i'm a
daughter of the american revolution
my family came over on the bristol
merchant and we settled pennsylvania
we've been in the military almost every
single generation
we fought in the civil war for the union
we died in the andersonville prison
camps
this is an epidemic
i am
i got very lucky in life though i was
very unfortunate but very fortunate
because i got two moms
i have my mom that was actually an nra
instructor
was
but it was there
and then i have a mom that i lost too
early
and her name is cece lyles
and she was an african-american woman
that raised me with my mom in a village
because they were police partners
and she gave her life
on flight 93 fighting off terrorists
i i wear these pens today mom's man
action almost an iron
i'm here both for
well both of my moms but for me
i'm 26 years old and
i'm medically retired
the symbol on the back of my shirt
that's for field artillery i got beard
guns in any of them
you can keep them
the price isn't worth it
you can keep my mother's guns
she quit the nra
you can keep
all of it if we can save kids if we can
stop these families these people from
being here
i don't know why the hell
my friend chelsea was up here earlier
and they got quiet
it got quiet when he brought up color
are you freaking kidding me
it shouldn't be a secret this this is
not a secret
this is a statistic and it's racist and
it's wrong and it's kind of narrow
now another thing i didn't tell you is
that i was actually in a school shooting
i know shocking right
had a long life
i got lucky because i got a call from my
mother
my over over anxious mother
that got me to go
to taco bell
my friend was trapped inside shows the
library when they started shooting it up
at florida state that 2014.
later
that year i would have to go back to my
hometown
because my uncle who was a war hero in
beirut bombings
well he had a ptsd attack you know
decades later
and he was armed
and so he was killed by swat
so i gotta
ask what
who are we doing this for
it is killing veterans it is killing
children it is killing all
of our citizens because these are our
citizens we are all citizens and we all
matter
their lives matter
and we gotta just
yeah i'll just
find a new hobby heavens
thank you so much for coming out today
[Music]
thank you so much all right we just have
three last speakers and then we're going
to wrap up so first i want to turn it
over to jamar brown
hey everybody
[Applause]
so my name is shamar brown i proudly
serve as co-executive director at the
texas democratic party and i came from
austin today to join you in solidarity i
came to join you in solidarity because
all of those children the children that
we lost this week and the children we
lost for years and for decades
they matter
and we've got to make sure that we keep
the energy that we have here today
now the power that we've shown across
the state and across the country told
greg abbott and then actually did not
appear in person but they did appear by
video and when they show you who they
are
believe them
they've shown us just as you said a
video doesn't mean you're off the hook
right
and so we march at the capitol we
testified we registered we voted we went
to the capitol and we told greg abbott
we told dan patrick that this is what's
going to happen that more people would
be in danger that we needed the permit
that we needed background checks that we
needed training and they didn't listen
and it didn't care now look where we are
and it's going to take all of us
together all of our collective energy
and action as we head to november
because marches and rallies and speeches
are great but the question is
what are we going to do at election time
what are we going to do
what are we going to do
and not only vote tell your friends
tell your neighbor and everybody you
know
not only vote for the governor
vote up and down the ballot because it
all matters it's not it's greg abbott
it's dan patrick it's kent coxton
that got us here
where we are right now and then don't
let them tell you this is not political
this is very political because bad
politics
bad leadership that passed bad laws got
us here
and it's going to take all of us to work
together to put the right people that
represent all of us in office i look
forward to standing with each and every
one of you here in houston and across
the state because it's going to be on us
to change this state and this state is
not going to change until we flip it and
we're going to take this energy not just
today not just tomorrow
but work every hour every week every day
every month until we make a difference
for all the families here and all the
families that are still grieving for
many years thank you all great to be
with you
[Music]
all right all right all right i've seen
the crowd and up since beth is gone
but you know what this is not about
social media
my name is angela i'm with the texas
coalition of black democrats montgomery
county chapter i'm the accountability
chair
and if you don't know what
accountability is it's going to depose
and voting those people out
ted cruz had the idea
cut out the freeze happened how many of
you all lost family in the freeze
think about it well he was the doctor
good going to cancun with his family and
that did not happen color on it
we lost people
sandy hook
colin fine
i have a baby that's five years old
he needs to be voted out we are tired of
just bending our hands and blowing our
hands and bending our knees and praying
and asking god for help because he's
gonna help us at the end of the day we
gotta help us
vote him out
[Applause]
hey y'all my name
is real quick so i'm max combat navy
right so why the [ __ ] am i dressed like
this this is the streets this is by the
way america i don't understand why we're
not [ __ ] angry children over three
thousand two those over 2 000 children
have been killed from school shootings
do you all realize that that should have
been done so long ago again we need to
progress and guess what our democrats
aren't doing stuff either we need to go
after them
i mean our constitutional rights are at
like more even these the supreme court
justice cells are kind of like oh it's
scary because they're taking women's
rights away they put policy the next day
to protect them that's actually against
my right to protest but whatever here we
are getting killed we need to go after
stop voting for people that slam the
door that black and brown women opened
my name is daniel cohen i'm a founder of
an organization called indivisible
houston
[Applause]
i'm going to keep this really short
because it's extremely hot and you've
heard from a lot of people who can tell
their personal story today i'll say two
things
one the shooter in buffalo apparently
believed that the jewish community was
putting the black community up to
attacking white people which is an
ancient and dangerous trope that makes
rounds across the street the national
rounds of tucker carlson nightly and
it's extraordinarily dangerous
it also shows that uh apparently
that guy had never been in a room with
someone like me and brandon before at
the same time
but i'm not here to make light
um the reason that i wanted to make sure
to address all of you and talk about it
is that today we've talked a lot about
getting involved and doing different
things voting or if it's chasing ted
cruz out of a restaurant or whatever it
is that you're going to do
make sure to get involved but if you're
wondering right now
how to get involved
you don't know what to do
you don't know what it means to go and
organize a precinct you don't know what
it means to attend another
protest or how you're going to find out
you happen to see this on facebook you
happen to see this on twitter and
otherwise you wouldn't have gotten here
today
talk to me i'm right here you can also
go to indivisiblehouston.org but make
sure you stay involved
if you're here today and you're not
normally out in the streets and this is
unusual for you i'm not mad at you i'm
proud of you i'm so happy you're here
but
we need you back
we all need each other for all the
elected officials that are here and it's
no shame to them they won't save us
we have to save us
so please stay involved talk to me i'm
here i will tell you how to get involved
if you don't know thank you very much
for coming today
hey y'all my name is odyssey i'm here
with the lgbtq plus caucus of houston
my
[Music]
my pronouns are they and them so please
do not call me ma'am you can call me
comrade though
[Music]
the people inside over there would like
you to think that this is about
absolutes that any restrictions on gun
usage is a total loss of freedom that
every time this happens via rob
elementary santa fe high school buffalo
new york or el paso walmart the culprit
is a lone wolf who acted absolutely
alone
that every one of these mass murderers
is mentally ill and bullied by his peers
and that a good guy with a gun on the
scene could have stopped him we know
that these are absolutely
lies
[Music]
we know that gun control when acted
enacted fairly and responsibly prevents
multiple daily mass shootings that white
male supremacy is an umbrella source of
these shootings that target black
indigenous people of color queer and
lgbtq plus people and women
that the people inside that building
provide community and support the
encouragement of these murderers that
oppressed minorities of color gender
sexuality and ability are rarely the
culprits
that those who are actually bullied such
as neurodivergent and mentally ill youth
are the main targets
that the good guy with a gun is
overwhelmingly the first target and shot
instead of being a help
that thoughts and prayers are useless
we also know that the solutions are not
in absolutes we know that gun control
such as red flag laws are necessary and
it is also necessary to ensure equality
in their enforcement
we know that police abolition will not
remove law enforcement entirely but it
will remove the extrajudicial and
arbitrary enforcement of those laws
we know that by calling on our elected
employees to restore funding to the
national center for injury prevention
and control and overturn the tr
amendment which can put in place
regulations that are data driven and
circumspect the criminalization of gun
records and gun tracing data prevents
policy makers from comprehensively
researching gun violence which allows
events like uvalde school to happen
we know that voting is not the end-all
be-all it is the beginning and if you're
represented by these absolute jackasses
you can drunk dial them and yell at them
you can protest at their home that is
our first amendment right
[Music]
hey y'all my name's tommy bay i'm a 16
year old young muslim which i'm not so
wild
and i just want to say i'm sick and
tired of being scared to go to school
it's ridiculous
the people that stand behind me today
care more about a group of cells than
the children that live in our schools
today
[Music]
and to the younger friends who weren't
here today i was let's say one thing
wait wait until names of victims
[Music]
not elijah accomplish it
you show up for me i'ma show up for you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for coming
you ain't got to go home but you got to
get out of here
black lives matter
[Applause]
[Music]
this week there are two disturbingly
interconnected stories coming out of
texas
the first is the one that's captured all
of our attention and horror new
questions are emerging today about how
an 18 year old with a variant of the
ar-15 rifle bought shortly after reached
the age of maturity walked into robb
elementary school in uvalde texas and
opened fire in a classroom killing 19
children and two teachers
the top cop in texas told reporters
yesterday that as much as an hour may
have passed between the gunman opening
fire and law enforcement officials
fatally shooting him
as footage like this emerged that
appeared to show parents and other
bystanders yelling at police to enter
the school nbc has not confirmed exactly
what time the video was recorded nor
what actions officers were taking in
that exact moment but footage captured
heated exchanges between onlookers and
authorities
man i can't be like that man
yeah i can't be like that when there's
people yes i do get across the street
because i'm having to deal with you get
across the
street across the street
one parent of a fourth grader told the
associated press and later
society is guilty
rather than the lawbreaker
[Applause]
it's time to restore the american
precept that each individual is
accountable
for his actions
and that's why we
the nra
will never ever stop fighting for the
right of the innocent in the law abiding
to defend themselves
against the evil criminal element that
plagues our society
because we know there can be no freedom
no security
no safety
without the right of the law abiding to
bear arms for self-defense
[Applause]
as we gather
we know the eyes of the nation
the eyes of history are upon us
and that's a good thing
because every american deserves to know
the truth
about who we are
and what we believe
so please
help me out here
let's give america a real clear view
how many police officers do we have here
today would you please stand up
retired police officers
would you please stand up
how about any firefighters
paramedics or first responders
[Applause]
any active military please stand and
remain standing
any veterans
please stand and remain standing
and let us recognize you this memorial
day weekend
anyone who works in health care in any
way
doctors
nurses
any teachers
if you work in education please stand to
remain standing
if you work in manufacturing
construction
please stand up
and if you work at any trade maybe a
truck driver a plumber or an electrician
and
[Applause]
and how about stay-at-home moms who work
harder than most people
ever
give them credit for
[Applause]
if you own your own business
stand up
any professionals accountants executives
law
are you a law abiding gun owner please
stand up and be recognized
we here today
[Applause]
and millions more like us
are patriotic americans
the heart and soul
of this country
we love our nation
we love
our children
grandchildren
friends
and family
and that's why we will always value
cherish
and protect
our fundamental human right to defend
ourselves
our communities
and our loved ones with our second
amendment right to bear arms
thank you
and god bless all of you
[Applause]
your executive director of the nra
institute for legislative action jason
we may
[Applause]
welcome everybody
welcome to the national rifle
association institute for legislative
action's annual leadership forum
as we begin today's program
ladies and gentlemen
please stand
and direct your attention to our flag
as texas's own armed citizen
jack wilson
leads us in our pledge
will you please join me in the pledge
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you jack
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing as jill nause white performs
our national anthem
[Music]
whose broad stripes in bright
stars through the peripherals
[Music]
we watched were so gallantly
streaming
and the
rockets red glare
[Music]
that i flag was still there
oh
say
does that star spangled
better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
of the
brave
[Applause]
that was awesome thank you jill
as we gather here
on this memorial day weekend
i think it's important that we all take
a moment
and reflect on the true meaning of this
holiday
i also think it's important
that we take a moment
to remember the lives that were lost in
the horrific tragedy
earlier this week in uvalde
so please join me stand one more time
in a sincere moment
of silence
and reverence
thank you all
friends
sadly
as wayne said
we can't legislate evil
out of someone's heart
and while prayer helps
and trust me i am a huge believer in
prayer
and we should never ever underestimate
the power of prayer
there are other things that we can do at
the same time
but condemning the nra
and law-abiding gun owners
for the evil acts committed by deranged
criminals is not one of them
[Applause]
over the last 10 years
we have called for more funding to
secure our schools
and help protect our teachers and
children
over the last 10 years
we've called for more resources to give
teachers and mental health experts the
ability to help kids in need
and over the last 10 years
we have called for fixing our broken
mental health system once and for all
and sadly
none of this has been done
government can somehow find a way to
print huge sums of money for hundreds of
pet projects but they can't seem to find
money to secure our schools and fix our
broken mental health system that's just
not right
[Applause]
and we at the nra
we grieve for the lost souls
and we at the nra
have heavy hearts
during these trying times
and we at the nra
want something meaningful done
that can actually solve the problem
not serve a political agenda
[Applause]
the only thing the 5 million members of
the nra do
is support and fight for a fundamental
human right
the hard working moms and dads
and sons and daughters of the nra man
they are good people
and the hard-working moms and dads
and sons and daughters of the nra are
law abiding people
we want and have always wanted to enact
real solutions to these serious problems
but those solutions do not come in the
form of failed gun control policies that
won't make anybody safer
[Applause]
and we will continue to oppose
all those failed policies
because they are not the answer and will
only endanger more people
and we're going to take this message to
congress the voters and ballot boxes all
across the country this november
thank you
god bless you
god bless america and god bless the nra
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
unfortunately our next speaker
is unable to be with us in person today
so please direct your attention to the
screens
for a message from texas governor greg
abbott
hi this is governor greg abbott and when
i say welcome to texas to everybody here
i come before you this afternoon
with a very heavy heart
america is grieving with an evil madman
that
took the innocent lives of school
children this past tuesday
moments like this
tear apart the very fabric of a
community
a community
that until tuesday
never thought that a tragedy like this
could ever happen in such a quiet south
texas town
like uvalde
this is the time of year that children
look forward to the end of the school
year
and the promise of summer
adventures but 19 innocent children
will never come home from that last week
of school
other children who survived
are scarred by what they witnessed
as texans
and as americans
we grieve and mourn with these families
the loss of their child is a tragedy
that no parent should ever have to
endure
as parents ourselves cecilia and i are
heartbroken by such a senseless tragedy
like this
we urge everyone here today everyone
across the country
to pray for those in uvalde who are
impacted by this atrocious act
the courageous actions of the many
teachers and staff at robb elementary
school to be applauded
these men and women are heroes for their
fearless defense
of the children in their charge
the lord teaches us
that every child is a precious gift
and evil stole those gifts from their
parents on tuesday
and also
remember this
there are thousands of laws on the books
across the country that limit the owning
or using of firearms
laws that have not stopped mad men from
carrying out evil acts on innocent
people
in peaceful communities
in uvalde
the gunman committed a felony under
texas law before he even pulled the
trigger
it's a felony to possess a firearm on
school premises
but that did not stop him
and
what he did on campus
is capital
murder
that's a crime that would have subjected
him to the death penalty in texas
well just as laws
didn't stop the killer
we will not let his evil acts stop us
from uniting the community that he tried
to destroy
i'm in uvalde this afternoon working to
heal the brokenhearted
we will bind up the wounds of the people
of uvalde
and once again restore the luster to a
community
known for its warmth
its friendship and its values
may god bless the people of yuvaldi and
may god forever bless
the great state of texas
[Applause]
our next speaker
grew up
on a farm and a ranch
she spent much of her time outdoors
and learned to hunt at an early age
a tradition she proudly passed down to
her three children
but she also knows that the second
amendment
is not about hunting
during her tenure in public service she
has worked tirelessly to protect our
second amendment right to keep and bear
arms
and to make sure that our kids
are safe
after being elected governor in 2018
the very first bill she signed into law
was constitutional carry
since then she has only continued to
sign more pro-gun legislation into law
making sure the second amendment and
freedom remain uninfringed ladies and
gentlemen it is my honor to introduce to
you the governor of south dakota
christie gnome
[Applause]
well good afternoon
thank you so much for that wonderful
welcome
you know it's an honor to be among a
group of america loving patriots like
all of you you have guts and you've got
conviction
you know it's inspiring to
look out on a crowd like this when i was
walking around the hall earlier today i
saw families i saw parents and
grandparents young women professionals
teenagers
hunters and sportsmen members of law
enforcement
nra members come from every single walk
of life
every race
every creed
and i am proud to be a lifetime nra
member and to stand with all of you
well welcome back everybody uh and by
that i mean i'm welcoming myself back uh
we are
approaching the speech of former
president donald trump it's hard to
imagine a more disgusting scenario than
celebrating guns three days four days
after the second worst mass shooting at
a school since sandy hook but alas here
we are this is south dakota governor
christie gnome
uh oh i'm i'm muted oh my god i've been
muted this entire time oh god how
humiliating
these people must think i'm an idiot
no okay all right let's get back to it
and we'll have time
are they having a break between speakers
does anybody know so we can chat the
grandmother
i can't even imagine what the families
of those dear children and those
teachers are going through i hope that
you are all lifting them up in prayer
and sadly it's not the first time that
we've experienced this type of grief i
think all of us here today and across
the country never want to see anything
like this ever happen again
but we have very many
difficult questions that we have to
answer today but
this isn't the time for grandstanding
it's not the time for shouting
or division
this is the time to be honest to work
together to protect the future for our
children and our grandchildren
to truly decide where we are going as a
country
we need to reflect on our history and
look back at where we've been
here are some of those questions why was
the second amendment even created
does it still hold value today
why is it okay for some to have guns and
others not
why do we protect our banks
our stores
and celebrities with armed guards but
not our children
are they not truly our greatest treasure
much much more valuable than material
things
if we limit the average citizen from
having a firearm will that keep those
who choose to ignore the law from
accessing one as well
listen i don't have all the answers for
you today but i do want to share with
you why i believe the second amendment
may be the most important of our bill of
rights the most important thing second
amendment is sacred to me and to our
family it always has been
you know unable to understand why it's
so important to us you need to know a
little bit about me personally
growing up on a farm in south dakota
guns were just a fact of life for my
family my dad was a farmer and a rancher
a real-life cowboy who worked harder
than anybody i had ever known oh he was
tough as rawhide he lived a life of
integrity and he expected his children
to embrace those ideals
of course this also applied to our
firearms owning guns wasn't a political
thing for us
like most american families we rarely
discussed government or politics around
the table
on our ranch our politics were lived not
talked about
we knew we had freedom and we had
personal responsibility
but we also knew that we needed to use
both to make our corner of the world a
better place to serve other people
it wasn't complicated
before i was old enough to get my own
hunting license i used to follow my
grandmother when she was out bird
hunting and yes
notice that this is all nonsense in the
sense that it does nothing she's not
saying here's how we reduce school
shooting she's just saying here's why i
don't want to do anything about guns
now my dad he preferred big game hunting
and from a young age my siblings and i
we went with him
we had guns hanging in the back window
of every pickup our gun cabinet was
proudly displayed in our living room
she's sort of saying like the fact that
i've managed not to be killed despite
growing up in a house full of guns means
we really can't restrict anybody's
access second amendment isn't about any
of that
the second amendment is about deterrence
it's about ensuring government respects
the rights it was literally an armed
police officer there didn't make a
difference it's funny
if the problem is mental illness
mentally ill people by their logic won't
be dissuaded by their being good guys
with guns they can't have it both ways
and for everybody saying oh what would
you do
i just put out a clip with a list of 10
things i would do
[Applause]
those 27 words are freedom's last line
of defense
the founders understood deeply that
without an armed citizenry authentic
freedom could not and would not survive
now how did they know this
what were their circumstances what did
they know about human nature and the
temptation to seize power
did they know how fragile freedom could
be
what were they drawing on
well number one they were drawing on
their own experience the founders knew
that the country would have never
survived the revolutionary war if the
colonists hadn't owned their own weapons
look at boston in 1775 11 000 expertly
trained british soldiers occupied the
city and george washington's ragtag army
of continentals surrounded them
his american volunteers carried only
their personal muskets
they used these to hold the british at
bay until a 25-year-old bookseller named
henry knox
the relevance of the guns that were
available then has a lot of bearing on
schools today huh in the meantime the
continentals challenged the infantry of
the british empire with the same
firearms that they used to hunt
squirrels and deer and to feed their
families
now what else did the founding
generation understand
they knew human nature
writing in 1775 thomas paine laid it out
clearly while avarice and ambition have
a place in the heart of man the weak
will become prey to the strong
the history of every age and nation
establishes these truths and facts need
but little arguments when they prove
themselves
when i read about the constitution i'm
often struck by this the subject and the
issue of timing
the first ten amendments the bill of
rights were ratified effective december
15
1791 but what else was happening in the
world at that time
the french revolution
unlike the u.s constitution the
declaration of the rights of man
the foundational document of the french
revolution does not include a right to
bear arms
and thomas payne's arguments proved
themselves in horrifying detail
in paris which was the center of
european learning and culture for a
thousand years mobs tore down statues
and
crosses does that sound familiar
they attacked religion
they desecrated churches
the mob consumed french society until a
dictator
could arise from all the chaos i know
many of you are saying how the hell does
this relate to what happened four days
ago and it doesn't they want you to
think it does they want you to think
there's some principle here
but it has nothing to do with it 1989.
he wrote civil rulers may attempt to
tyrannize
and the military forces which must be
occasionally raised to defend our
country might pervert their power to the
injury of their fellow citizens
does this mean that at the time the
constitution was ratified the founders
might have been worried
about a corrupt american government
using the military to crush the rights
of regular citizens
it sure sounds that way doesn't it
so let's talk about the cities with the
most restrictive gun control oh here we
go when 30 people are shot over a
weekend in chicago we get nothing but
silence from it's 30 minutes from
indiana guys members kill innocent
children in baltimore or cleveland they
might give it a passing mention on the
local news
but when a deranged mentally unstable
murderer who fits the left's political
narrative kills innocent children
and people the media seizes the
opportunity to paint millions this is
this is even worse than i expected i
have to this it's hard to imagine
something more depressing than what
they're doing here
these arguments work on idiots
says one of our viewers but there's a
lot of idiots in this country they're
running the show idiots are in charge
they use the tragic situation to push
their agenda and it is all about control
and it is garbage
i'm not buying it for a second and you
shouldn't either
there's this very specific i'm not i i'm
not being
sexist here i'm just describing there's
this very specific delivery that some
conservative
uh
women
politicians have that is extraordinarily
like ignorant and low brow and
christinome has it and it seems to
resonate with a lot of these right
wingers i think they find it in some way
like um
uh
i don't know what the right word is
it's like an accent slash delivery i
don't know how to describe it we're
women
they find it alluring yeah
and almost 60 percent of them were over
the age of 45.
[Music]
[Applause]
i believe the number one reason
was because of fear of civil unrest and
to protect themselves and their families
we have seen the same type of radical
mob mentality taking place on the
streets of american cities that swept
paris in the 1790s woke mobs are tearing
down statues and it doesn't matter who
they are above
it kind of does matter imagine being
like a woke mob is tearing down statues
of hitler oh that doesn't sound that bad
actually that sounds reasonable it kind
of does matter what the statues are
dangerous women very dangerous on cue
the left and their media allies cheered
them on remember when chris cuomo was
asking where in the constitution it says
protests have to be peaceful
well it's in the first sentence in the
first amendment chris look it up
[Applause]
of course
all right i'm gonna mute christy gnome a
little bit because it is it is
nauseating um we were scheduled to start
this at 2 p.m east sorry 3 p.m eastern
and then it was announced trump would be
two and a half hours late i'm not
exaggerating he would be two and a half
hours late
so we are back again
uh and it is extremely wild let me say
thank you and read some messages some
beautiful super chats coming in hawkeye
heyoka with a 50 super chat says david
thank you for covering this thank you
for your logic and reasoning i find your
channel a beacon of light during these
dark times well thank you for your
generosity
another 50 super chat from peter
williams who says it's crazy how
questioning these insane solutions is
the exception not the norm in the
mainstream media peel them back a
millimeter and it's obvious it's bs i
have no confidence this will get better
until we challenge this as the norm
absolutely well said
daniel silva says this dystopia sucks
can we change multiverses i know
it's it's so backwards austin says these
people are sick
governors christie naomi and greg abbott
costello need help
yeah
it's uh
it's absolutely nuts now what did
someone say here trump won't show up
until the protest outside is gone well
then he then he might not make it uh
these mirrors are teleprompters guys
remember when obama using a teleprompter
was bad obama yeah but teleprompters
prevent humiliating mistakes we've
endorsed jp right j.d mandel yeah that's
why the teleprompters are there um we do
we want to listen to greg abbott talking
about the shooting a little bit i think
we do let's see what the latest version
they're coming up with to stitch back
together
the fabric of yuvaldi
helping us to do that
is the leader of uvalde himself
and that is the mayor of uvalde who i
would like to ask to speak at this time
governor i'd like to thank you for
bringing all these state agencies here
and the services you've offered our
community our citizens because these
families are going to need this help not
just today but in the long term as you
mentioned so for that
governor i i appreciate and i'm
you know all i can say is i've seen you
these last two days in the compassion
and
and
no along with these families and that i
i just i really admire it i thank you
and
like i said and we appreciate everybody
from all over the world and the country
that has sent
messages of encouragement and so forth i
mean
our hearts are broken here in uvalde
it's a very
i mean you know nobody ever wants to
have to go through this especially as a
mayor i never thought this was something
i would have to go through my heart's
broken for these families but the one
good thing about our community is
evaluating is a strong community i think
if some of you reporters have been here
well enough you'll see that
there's a lot of unity in our community
and it will take some time but we will
get over this and your value will come
back stronger we're going to get over it
we'll change nothing but we'll get over
it
someone who has been actively engaged in
helping
the victims of crime already
and will remain engaged all the way
through
is the district attorney christina
mentioned
thank you governor for being here
and we want to thank everybody that's
reached out to us in evaldi from across
the state from across the country and
across the world we greatly appreciate
all the support and kind words and
prayers and assistance that has been
sent to us and like the mayor said here
in uvalde county we are down to earth
people we are salt of the earth people
and we are a family and like a family
we're going to get through this together
with each other and for each other and
we're asking everybody across the world
to continue to support us so i the
district attorney along with the fbi
victims assistance people the dps victim
assistance people the attorney general's
office we have set up a family
assistance center at the uvalde county
fairplex here in uvalde and at that
center it's a one-stop shop for all the
victims
and we say victims we meet everybody
that was associated with rob yeah
diana says thoughts on beto confronting
abbott at the press conference the other
day i absolutely loved it diana
absolutely loved it i think it was uh
excellent got a ton of attention
and it needs to be you know all of these
things every listen to all the things
they're saying
we have a family assistance phone line
okay fine good good uh we're gonna get
over this
nobody's saying we're gonna change a
damn thing because they don't plan to
they don't plan to change a damn thing
it's it's absolutely uh uh disgusting
thanks to deep doob canadians fearing
america avalanche of spinach andre
bavaria and van top tv
for the twitch subscriptions putting us
at 113 i also
i can't thank enough some amazing people
who have just gotten a ton of
memberships on my website eric
lobazinski betsy wonder susan linscott
michael doctor alexandra massimino kelly
white lisa common and andrew avdrum's
gifting two subscriptions
desiree de long gifting one sam
hendrickson getting a membership that's
11 putting us at 124
for the day
thank you so much i so appreciate that
would i debate or discuss gun violence
with ben shapiro again anytime
absolutely any time i will do it
um
yeah let's listen to a little more here
turned tail and he had ran
here's what grant wrote of that event
from that event to the close of the war
i never once experienced trepidation
upon confronting an enemy again
though i always felt more or less
anxiety i never forgot that he had as
much reason to fear my forces as i had
of his
the left likes to appear
monolithic
unstoppable sickening but it's not
and what's more the left is afraid of
the nra
we're afraid of all the people that are
dying thanks to the nra
they fear people who think for
themselves and who defend their rights
there's so many they don't think for
themselves they just say whatever the
nra tells them to say
so don't back down
now is not the time to quit
now would be the worst time to quit
now
is when we double down
double down on what
[Applause]
lastly what does it look like when a
person embraces their fundamental rights
and responsibilities i think it's clear
that they become more free
they become more capable more
independent more powerful
more free
we are all called to live courageously
in the battlefield of our daily lives
our workplaces our communities our homes
our country needs it no weak-willed or
half-measures will save us from the
relentless and the unhinged radicals
that we are facing today
so we double down
this fight is much bigger than the
people in this room
the consequences of our actions will
affect all future generations of
americans
do you want your children to have the
same freedom that we've been blessed
with
i want there to be fewer school
shootings and she hasn't proposed one
way to make that happen oh and
experience liberty
then we must protect the second
amendment
it is an honor
[Applause]
it is an honor to be in this getting
some backup streams going forward
today so thank you for your work
god bless you and may god continue to
bless the great united let's switch over
here
oh
well that was really a great uplifting
speech today
and not exactly
not exactly uh all right this nonsense
continues uh building up eventually um
to donald trump and i i am with you guys
this is absolutely vile and disgusting
story with you
last august
brevard county florida sheriff's
deputies were conducting a joint
operation with members of the united
states border patrol along interstate
95.
during the operation
deputy tyler thomann conducted a traffic
stop on a vehicle near west melbourne
florida
during this routine stop
things went drastically wrong
when one of the individuals in the
vehicle produced a stolen firearm and
began to fire at tyler and the other
deputies
the suspect in this case
was a career criminal with over 40
previous arrests including 23 violent
felonies
was out on bond for two felony drug
charges and had two felony warrants
outstanding when the incident occurred
deputy tyler thomann exhibited
exceptional bravery and courage
while facing the armed violent suspect
and his actions
not only saved his life but the lives of
his fellow deputies
sure as such
it is with great honor and pride
that the national rifle association
names deputy tyler thomann as the 2022
nra law enforcement officer of the year
deputy please oh my god
this is one of the do you do you realize
what the rest of the world thinks when
they see an event like this
they think we're completely insane in
this country
and much of the country is
it's uh
they brought a baby oh my god
this this it's it's just stunning
stunning that this is what's happening
um
wow
hey david this is daniel from dc um i'm
a big fan of what you're doing and i've
been listening to you for a few years
um first time calling and it seems to me
that you've become steadily more
pessimistic about the direction of our
country you think
you think daniel by the right pivot um
and you know quote unquote policy
um
where do you see the u.s in let's say 20
or maybe 50 years well it doesn't sound
good
it doesn't sound good this is
this this is this is a sick country it's
an ill country i don't know how else to
describe it now fortunately things are a
lot less crazy in the blue states
uh it's not perfect but but it's a lot
less crazy in the blue states
let's see what's coming up next right to
self-defense outside your home
he's been alongside us every step of the
way oh no filing briefs and unabashedly
taking on the gun control media
please join me in welcoming one of the
most fearless defenders of the second
amendment from the lone star state
senator ted cruz
and we will ban men
oh no
we'll just listen to a little i know
it's it's this is the i would get the
kids out of the room yeah this is it's
very gross
[Applause]
i want to speak today
on the nature of evil
we're gathered today
under crushing darkness
on tuesday
less than 300 miles away
an evil man murdered 19 children
and two teachers
within hours
i was on a plane back to texas from
washington blaming doors instead of guns
today in uvalde
there i sat down with law enforcement
with local officials
and i joined in a community prayer vigil
that evening
prayer okay as the entire community was
reeling
from the shooting
we prayed together
and we cried together
why does no one ever ask why didn't we
use prayer to prevent the shooting why
are we only using prayer after the fact
urged to describe
a monster
who enters a school
and murders little children
19
little kids
19 families in uvalde who lost
their little boys
and their little girls
two families of teachers
who aren't here with us anymore
none of us will ever truly understand
the manifest evil
that devastated yvaldi on that day we do
understand the evil of the nra however
the entire country oh yeah let's go over
oh they're not even carrying it sorry
guys
and grieving
and it is an evil that has happened too
many damn times
light applause for that
in the last several years especially
texas has repeatedly seen the face
of evil yeah
repeatedly makes you think i've been on
the ground
after these tragedies on the ground in
cancun
after another
i was in dallas in 2016
in sutherland springs in 2017 in santa
fe in 2018 in el paso and midland odessa
in 2019
and now you've aldi
and i still won't change anything
was the picture of horror
if children are the picture of innocence
then the lunatics and the monsters like
this one the one who would deliberately
murder children
they are the picture of evil
many of us
in this room
our mothers and fathers now are they
evil or mentally ill because mental
illness isn't evil it's an illness so is
he now going with evil or are they still
going with mentally ill
of those families right now is
unimaginable
the very worst pain on earth
all of us in texas
need to come together
and comfort those families right now we
need to love them
embrace them and take care of them
very light applies
the most applause was when christie
gnomes said the second amendment is the
most important thing for all of this
stuff about the victims there's very
very sparse applause
there's another consistent pattern that
i've seen
repeatedly
despite the darkness
i've seen love
and compassion and herald there's this
crazy pattern
the more guns per capita a country has
the more shootings per capita a country
has
it's perplexing but it's evil
and lay people coming together
and standing as one
no matter the horror
our state's response to each act of evil
to each challenge has been zero has
always been one of unity
and strength and resilience
yuvaldi is strong
texas is strong and the entire country
stands alongside the men and women who
are grieving in you of aldi today
we will get through this
and we will come through this
together
at the same time
it is incumbent on us to understand what
is behind
these evil
attacks
well you know when we were growing up
this kind of thing didn't happen
kids may have worried about getting into
a fist fight at school
maybe a bloody nose at recess
but we never worried about a psychopath
coming into our classrooms to commit
murder what
the
the elites
who dominate our culture anybody know
what that person yelled out firearms
lie at the root of the problem
by elites
i refer to some of the most powerful
politicians and their allies in the
media
the leaders of the largest corporations
and many of the most famous celebrities
and those who echo and amplify them
their resources are limitless
their megaphone is
enormous and their voice can be
deafening it sounds like it's not a gun
issue according to ted
from behind great bulwarks of safety
from gated communities equipped with
private security or at the very least
from safe and expensive neighborhoods
protected by high home prices
like where ted lives
such people can afford an indulgent
ideology
that ignores reality
as is so often the case
those furthest from the halls of power
are the most dependent on the ability to
defend themselves
for millions of americans the right to
keep and bear arms is not theoretical
it's not abstract
for a single mom in a dangerous
neighborhood
it is a matter of basic security
taking guns away from these responsible
americans
will not make them safer
nor will it make our nation
more secure
hard to believe in an age where elites
embrace defunding the police
when homelessness runs rampant
when gangs dominate entire communities
and when radical district attorneys
refuse to prosecute violent crime in
cities across america
rarely
has the second amendment been more
necessary to secure the reducing the
number of guns won't reduce the number
of shootings
says a guy from the country with the
most guns and the most shootings
but many would still tell us that the
evil on display in uvalde or in buffalo
derives from the presence of guns yeah
it's also funny because if you look at
the 10-point list i proposed not a
single one of the things i proposed
would take away that gun from the
imaginary mom he's talking about but
four of the things would have limited
this particular shooter's ability to
have the particular guns that he had
so there are plenty of solutions that i
mean listen the ten i proposed would not
prevent that mom from having the gun she
might have had to wait a few days the
waiting period she would have had to
have a background check she would have
to get insurance
but she would still be able to have her
gun requires a sick soul
to drive a truck
into a crowded sidewalk
to plan a bomb
at a marathon
or to fly a plane
into a building
it requires a sick soul to open fire in
a movie theater
or in a church
right they're still pretending that at
the aurora movie theater shooting dark
room
guns start going off okay
they're still pretending that having
more people in there in the dark with
guns would have helped anything it's
it's one of the most delusional examples
of this
forcing us to ask hard questions
demanding that we see where our culture
is failing
well we know where it's from
looking at broken families
absent fathers
declining church attendance social media
bullying
church attendance is the reason for the
shootings
in video games
chronic isolation
[Applause]
prescription drug and opioid abuse and
their collective effects on the psyche
of young americans this is quite frankly
a fascist diatribe this this is crazy
faceted
it's a lot easier to moralize about guns
and to shriek
about those you disagree with
politically
but it's never been about guns
we know that places with some of the
most restrictive gun laws places like
chicago and baltimore and washington d.c
they don't have less gun violence
indeed
they contain some of the most dangerous
communities
on the face of the earth
we also know that their communities in
places like texas with extraordinarily
high rates of gun ownership
an extraordinarily low rates
of gun violence
we know that keeping guns away from
citizens who follow the law
does very little to keep them away from
criminals
who ignore the law
we know that there are no more guns per
capita in this nation today
than there were 50 or 100 years ago
that's worth underscoring
in 1972 the rate of per capita gun
ownership in the united states was 43
percent
in 2021
the rate is 42 percent
the rate of gun ownership hasn't changed
and yet acts of evil like understand
that that's deceptive those the the guns
per capita and the rate of gun ownership
are two different things well tell us
these horrific crimes occur
only in america
that simply
isn't true oh the data show according to
the crime prevention research center
quote
out of the 101 countries where we have
identified mass public shootings
occurring
the united states ranks 66th in the per
capita frequency of these attacks and
56th
in the murder rate
but to be clear
one
is one too many
we know that many of these
who seek to commit the most heinous
crimes
they're isolated from human contact
they're living a virtual life in the
absence of community and faith and love
none of that
excuses their heinous acts none of that
reduces the evil of their deity
but these are questions we have to
answer
if we want to rescue our country
i ask these cultural questions because
mere technocratic solutions
the acts of legislators or of government
regulators will not alone
solve what ails us
and those who proclaim that it will
are not telling you the truth
they are demagoguing
for political gain
now some may be naive enough to confuse
their virtue signaling
with real solutions
but most are engaged in the most cynical
kind of politics
they say
as president obama did that imagine
speaking at the nra and saying other
people are engaged in cynical politics
do something
they demand
and here perhaps to the surprise of some
i emphatically agree
there have been too damn many of these
killings and we must act decisively to
stop them okay
and what would you do
but what is the something right
we should do
to washington democrats
the answer is so-called universal
background we know we know it's not guns
but give us the answers is he going to
mention doors here maybe windows sinks
and showers
all firearms
here's the problem
their so-called solutions
wouldn't have stopped these mass murders
and they
know this
four of the things i proposed would have
had an impact
the uvalde shooter and i won't use his
name and nor should anyone else he
should fade into eternal anonymity wow
what courageous
what courage
[Applause]
but that son of a [ __ ] passed a
background check
as for so-called assault rifles
which the left and the media love to
demonize
these guns were banned for 10 years from
1994
to 2004
and the department of justice examined
the effect of the ban
and concluded that it had zero
to statistically significant effect
it had zero tests testicular effect yeah
um that's not my understanding of the
data by the way but i don't have it in
front of me i know it won't work
that won't stop
these horrific crimes
answer for too many of them is that
their real goal
now again if you look at my list of
proposals
if you can't have high capacity firearms
under age 25
the shooter would have maybe gotten a
handgun you don't kill as many people
with the handgun
if you're under 25
you need two or three letters from
community adults saying they think it's
a fine idea for you to have firearms
based on what we know about this guy he
might not have been able to get those
letters if you had been required to have
gun insurance
it's possible that that would have made
it inconvenient or priced him out so so
the idea that nothing will do anything
no no no there's lots of things that
could be done
and the reason is simple the law abiding
citizens
follow the law
but the criminals do not that is why
they're criminals
but let me tell you what would happen
if they succeeded in confiscating guns
confiscating many more people understand
offering a buyback is a different thing
autistic from the obama white house
hardly a right-wing source
guns
are used defensively
to stop a crime
between five hundred thousand and one
million times
every
single
year
uh harvard has studied this guns are not
used 500 000 to a million times each
year in self-defense
there are uh it's actually
extraordinarily rare
um you can look this up harvard injury
control research center
um
most purported self-defense gun uses are
actually
gun uses in escalating arguments they
aren't something that we should uh cheer
and firearms are used far more often to
intimidate than in self-defense and
later reported as i just use my gun
defensively that's not what is happening
let's focus on what works stopping the
bad guys imprisoning violent criminals
and protecting
are vulnerable
understand a ton of these defensive gun
uses are you have an argument in your in
your yard
just an argument with an unarmed person
you pull your gun out
the person flees
and that gets reported as a defensive
gun use
give me a break guys
give me a break
grassley cruz did three things
first
it would mandate that the department of
justice conduct an audit of federal
agencies
to make sure that all felony convictions
have been reported to the database
second
grassley cruz would create a gun crime
task force at the department of justice
specifically to prosecute felons or
fugitives who try to buy firearms
illegally
in 2010 there were so
four of my ideas would have affected the
uvalde shooter so far none of ted's
would have affected the uvalde shooter
just as prosecuted
only 44 of them
that
is indefensible
third
grassley cruz would have authorized 300
million dollars
for school safety improvement grants
to harden our schools oh god when
grassley cruz came to the senate floor
for a vote in 2013
52 senators voted yes
including nine democrats yeah there's a
good point which is like the hardened
felons
oh by the way this this loser here yeah
of course david you know how to fix
everything well no but hold on a second
see that
i'm getting the sense that that's not a
good faith comment look at my video
look at my 10 proposals and critique
each of them individually that's the way
we evaluate these things
could have stopped at least some no i
won't ban that guy he can for now he can
hang out grassley cruz is a perfect
example
take sutherland springs
there it was already illegal
for the shooter to purchase firearms
doubly so because he was a felon and
because he had a domestic violence
conviction
so how did he get his guns
because the obama air force
failed to report his felony conviction
to the database
and so he passed the background check
that is almost never the issue i'm with
him on this you've got to report it you
but it's almost never the issue
his felony conviction
and the gun crimes task force would have
prosecuted him for the felony of lying
on the background check form
yeah maybe i mean it's actually pretty
rare that people even get prosecuted for
that that's the other part of this
federal prison
instead of murdering 26 innocent people
in that beautiful sanctuary
to this day
i don't know if any reporter has asked
even a single democrat
why they filibustered bipartisan gun
violence legislation
that could have made a real difference
saving lives
so what about uvalde
well part of grassley cruz was 300
million dollars to upgrade school
security
because we've seen a tragic pattern
repeat
when i sat down with the families at
santa fe
we discussed how that monster
had entered through an unlocked back
door
how he'd been able to make it to a
classroom unimpeded
and murder innocent children
we also know that there are best
practices at federal buildings and
courthouses
where for security reasons they limit
the means of entry
to one entrance
i still don't get how this is a solution
because then everybody gets funneled in
through the same place can't the shooter
just wait right where that one spot is i
mean i just maybe i'm too stupid to
understand this brilliant idea fire
exits should only open
out
at that single point of entry
we should have multiple
armed police officers
all right
i mean listen i would get rid of the
windows anybody could shoot through a
window too veterans train to provide
security and keep our children safe
[Applause]
maddeningly the shooter in uvalde
cut in the exact same way
the santa fe shooter did
he walked through an unlocked back door
into an open classroom
we need serious funding
to upgrade our schools to install
bulletproof doors and locking classroom
doors these schools are sounding more
and more like prisons
what about a moat and a higher law
enforcement to protect our most precious
asset
there's some degree to which this feels
kind of like the hey you know what was
the rape victim wearing were they
properly protected from the rape
versus like oh if we just reduce the
number of people trying to rape we might
be better off [ __ ] my legislation to
allow schools to access
1.3 billion dollars
in federal funds to improve school
safety
had uvaldi gotten a grant to upgrade the
school security
they might have made changes that could
have stopped this shooter and killed him
at the single point of entrance with
armed law enforcement there on the
ground before he hurt any of these
innocent kids and teachers
[Applause]
it does feel like the nra must be
struggling as a result of this right i
mean there i know that tons of people
still love it but i would be very
curious what the effect is of this
entire fiasco on their membership
[Applause]
like stephen williford the heroic
plumber and nra rifle instructor who
grabbed his ar-15 and ran barefoot to
stop the murderer at sutherland springs
[Applause]
or the border patrol tactical unit who
finally killed the uvalde monster
[Applause]
and that's why the media's cynicism
and dishonesty on this topic is so
pernicious
the media blames you
the millions of members of the nra
for these crimes
that didn't the sutherland shooting
end because the shooter just crashed his
car like i
i don't even know about these examples
like you have to research every single
thing this guy says
has committed these kinds of unspeakable
crimes
everybody here is horrified utterly
horrified
by these mass murders
but more importantly but it is the
law-abiding patriots here like stephen
williford who over and over and over
again step up and risk their lives to
stop these depraved lunatics
the media
wanted all of us
to stay away
but you are not the cause
of this evil
instead you are fighting to defend the
bill of rights to keep people safer in
their homes and on the subway to protect
our families
you are the veterans the law enforcement
members the courageous men and women
who rise to defend your fellow neighbors
we must not react
to evil
and tragedy
by abandoning the constitution or
infringing on the rights
were not citizens
now is not the time to yield to panic or
intimidation or fear now is not the time
for lies it is not the time for empty
political gestures
now is the time for unity
now is the time for love
and now is the time for action to
protect our rights
to stop those with evil in their hearts
and to do everything humanly possible
to protect our children
and to protect our families
god bless you
well one of the most dangerous speeches
i have ever seen since i have been
covering politics
uh i tweeted as much just moments ago
absolutely absurd although i have a
feeling maybe the next speech from
donald trump could be even worse so
welcome everybody if you're just joining
us we're standing by for donald trump's
speech at the national rifle association
convention i want to say thanks to hat
mumphrey lucon and the brandy alexander
for the twitch subscriptions also
seriously really big thank you jim
custer just got a membership on my
website joinpakman.com
and emily rose skinner got a membership
on my website using the coupon code
obama obama uh i invite you to sign up
you go to joinpakman.com
you pick the membership of your choice
monthly or yearly i love yearly
personally
and then indeed typing in obama
look at what this does for us isn't that
incredible
it's an unbelievable thing
uh as we stand by here
uh for president a former failed failed
former former failed failed for now i
think failed former failed former
president donald trump who will be
speaking and i'm sure it will be
incredibly powerful
thanks for searching for cheese for the
twitch subscription you're number 130
today super chats are continuing to dump
in were there not armed police outside
the school for 40 minutes were they not
good enough guys
good question samantha maybe schools
should have a 20 foot high electrified
fence as well absolutely
an ar-15 would allow a shooter to pick
off security police at a distance which
pistols would be ineffective
true
now is not the time for empty political
jesters says jester cruz
um
who's this guy wonderful blessings that
we have
without him this nation would be not be
what it is so we give him thanks
first and foremost
for all of those wonderful blessings
well is that a towel
let me say first off
that my heart is broken for the people
of uvalde
those parents who lost children those
loved ones
all those friends
neighbors all right i don't even know
that we necessarily want to listen to
this talking about unity wait until you
hear the master divider mr trump i know
what do you think about shootings like
the virginia tech shooting where 32
people died and the shooter used
handguns okay every situation is
different no one rule will stop every
shooting please watch my video
about this i address that
the existence of the nra and the
narrative that we need to defend
ourselves perfectly encapsulates how
ineffective our law enforcement system
is right we're not doing anything about
the pressing need to have to defend
ourselves
hey david not gonna lie as someone who
moved to texas last year ted cruz is
making a great case for moving out of
here
that's oh okafor who's called into the
show many times
um
yeah
let's keep doing nothing and expecting
something to change i know
i know
it's uh
it's it's disturbing there's no other
way to say it
um
here's juan about the prayer question i
raised
hey david you asked about
why do they pray
after
the killings right children
and people
and uh
to prevent deaths
from killing yeah pray before to pray
pray that there's no shooting you know
with guns
the reason they don't pray for
prevention is because
there is a possibility that their gun
sales might go down ah there you go
i think juan has become woke
juan is starting to understand
the nra
uh i want to say thanks to hudson markle
who just signed up on my website chris
wicht
just signed up on my website and molly
little molly using the coupon code obama
new members number 131 132 and 133 today
other super chats can cruise is coming
for your doors bonjour from montreal
uh i will be in montreal very very
powerfully very soon
david sir cruz claimed people go to the
u.s because it's the safest yet people
here in finland won't even visit out of
fear of being shot you know where i felt
really safe
when i was in finland i have to tell you
it it just felt extremely safe
denver says sorry if you address this
what are your thoughts expectations
about mitch mcconnell instructing a
republican senator to reach out to the
democrats to pass something i haven't
heard about that actually denver so i
can't uh i can't i can't say much about
it yet
but we will i i will look at look at it
hey david listen to the show right now i
have an interesting question for you
hopefully interesting yeah let me decide
whether the questions are interesting
please uh you said that there there's a
lot of people who think like these
people at the nra convention uh
however i i hear all the time the 90 of
americans support uh gun control
legislation no 88 of americans
want universal background checks that's
very specific now the nra doesn't
but it's it's you have to be much more
specific than that
it's much it's a much narrower claim
um chakaseki says ted cruz is more
unhinged than doors that haven't been
installed well said chakaseki
poke the bear says david prediction for
tonight's celtics game celtics end the
series tonight and go to the nba finals
that's my prediction
they don't pray before because the
shootings would still happen and then
they would have to defend god's inaction
that's a risky prayer
that's that's tough language that's
tough language but i can't say that it's
inaccurate i really can't
memberships are dumping in almost faster
than i can keep track thanks to cam
wilder darren o'shaughnessy
lynn gillully
and jonathan banuelos for signing up on
my website putting us at 137
many people using the coupon code obama
obama
sir when i joined the marine corps in
2013 i was taught that a rifle is a tool
not a toy
nor should it be used as a political
campaign prop well said danny
well said
uh and thanks to endeavors for the super
chat yeah i mean hard to say it any
better than that
uh voicemails are pouring in about the
absurdity of this convention
hey david andrew listen i have a ton of
friends in um
denmark
and norway and spain and they first of
all i don't think they even see this i
don't think they're they're even getting
to see this type of uh
rhetoric for this nra conference yeah
it's insane
and the people that i talk to that do
see this kind of thing or if i send it
to him yeah
we're cooked this really sucks yep all
right listen
everybody i know
ev everywhere people i know in europe
people i know in argentina obviously
people i know in canada people i know in
israel
australia new zealand
nobody can understand what the hell is
going on in this country and how you
wouldn't go like hey listen
let's just kind of try like really
restricting the guns
you can still get them
you can still get them i mean again you
know i've said before i don't really
talk about my personal gun ownership one
way or the other i've never talked about
whether i do or don't own guns but as
many of you know you know i i live live
in cities and there's lots of places
where it's much more rigorous you can
still do it but it's much more rigorous
and everyone i know
has no problem with that it should be
difficult
there's no problem with that um let's
see what else we got
hey david bradley from new york here
um i saw a super chatter mentioned uh
mcconnell
uh wanting to pass something for
for gun control
it was came out yesterday that he
instructed texas senator cornyn
to work with uh democrats um including
chris murphy
to pass something
that would be a big deal if it happened
i just haven't heard that yet
i just haven't heard that yet
um
but listen i mean pass something
um ryan ben you know the the risk with
passing something that does nothing is
that then they go hey we did it we did
it that's it we're not doing anything
else because we did it
that's that's the risk
uh thanks to ryan benson for gifting a
subscription and patrick darnell just
grabbed a subscription on my website as
well that's numbers 138 and
also thank you to user beef goggles beef
goggles very powerfully getting a twitch
prime subscription which we love we love
twitch prime
uh and associated subscriptions
more people continuing to call in about
this conference
hey david
i'm watching your uh live stream right
now and uh looking at the chat and some
of the right-wingers in your chat
and i noticed that uh
the write seems to be more upset that
we're still talking about this than the
fact that it happens yes
um
it seems like uh
they seem to care more about their guns
than they do the lives of children
and i was curious and i know yeah
they're open listen they don't want
children to die they're open to saving
children as long as it doesn't impact
their gun ownership this probably sounds
mean but
at what point can we just call these
people evil sociopaths i'm going to
leave that to the audience
i don't want to uh
get get too involved in that hey david
if sarah from math hey i agree with you
on these cops not going in and
everything uh officer tatum right now is
doing a live on where everyone was
positioned why they didn't do it
or whatever but i mean i don't know how
many excuses they can have i i have
total agreement with you for the first
time ever i think oh wow eric from mass
even uh
when eric from mass is even remotely
reasonable
you know things have gotten pretty crazy
tesla driving vegan has just gotten a
twitch subscription which we love
also thanks to jason sickmeyer for
gifting another subscription on my
website i really appreciate that
other super chats coming in no we don't
have any okay let's see if we can do
maybe just one more voicemail here trump
expected to speak any second
hey david this is justin uh just wanted
to talk about the whole
locked door or single point of entry
which is such a bs argument in the first
place but i just wanted to correct the
idea that a single point of entry does
not mean a single point of egress i i
have stated that multiple times every
time i mention
they're talking about exit doors with
the push bar so it's locked from the
outside but you can exit that i i
understand that i've been saying that
uh all all along okay it is believed
that donald trump is the next speaker
although whether he's going to speak
immediately we don't really know
uh aiden murphy says via super chat ted
cruz says talking about guns is playing
politics by his own standards with
peaking at a gun convention not be
political there is nothing more
political than this event
it's it's impossible to say we shouldn't
politicize this issue
and then to hold an nra convention
well
who's speaking next oh my god i have a
feeling they're going to bring on some
other ranters
[Applause]
here they go
in 1992 to serve as a conduit to help
support oh god i can't even do it i
can't even do it i don't even want to
know what they're donating to
it can only be absurd
i can only imagine how insane it is
let's see
what else we've got here
as far as the conference goes hey david
my name is kenzie i'm a teacher in the
houston area i really wanted to go to
the nra protest today but unfortunately
had to work
um i just wanted to say thank you for
your coverage of all of these events i
am right outside of santa fe so i
experienced that firsthand i had friends
who lost siblings in that shooting and
now with this shooting and there was an
active shooter on the campus that i work
at um
it is very frustrating to be in
education right now and
to try and tell my students that it's
going to be okay and i
don't know that it's going to be okay
right but people like you and your
coverage uh really
motivate me to keep fighting the good
fight and help my kids realize that
there are good people in this world even
if they aren't in power right now wow so
just a big thank you
well thank you kenzie what a beautiful
message that i that's that's a that's a
fantastic message
uh
as as the evil wayne lapierre walks on
stage i really appreciate that voicemail
gwj says just spoke with parents about
the recent shootings they seem way more
concerned with additional security than
actually addressing any of the cultural
problems with guns or the access yep
it's depressing
it's depressing for sure with without a
doubt
um
it's um
yeah i don't it's it's it's beyond words
quite frankly
uh change out a little bit of
teleprompter stuff
they have to set up trump's proper
teleprompter now before he speaks
wow
wow
what what an absurd situation
uh here's another voicemail about this
hey david patman this is kevin from
branson missouri you just want to let
you know i do not agree with the uh
the children's being killed but i think
and i do not agree with the teachers
having the guns but i do agree with
them being more protective like trying
to teach the kids how to protect
themselves more
but uh yeah i enjoy your show i'm
enjoying you having live coverage on
everything pretty much
and i enjoy
you as a host you're a pretty good host
and just please put this on the air
so everybody can hear my point of view
i did i think that i am a republican at
heart yes but i do have
some theories or stuff but i mean it's
i mean i don't know i don't know what
you think but do you think that the nra
when this nra thing happens do you think
that this is going to be like another
january 6th thing where they no it
doesn't it does it's going on right now
and it doesn't it doesn't seem like
there's a riot outside um i do want to
thank you though for boldly taking the
stance that you're against the kids
dying i think that that's important
hey david i think the only way to really
fix this issue is by arming the school
children i believe
by arming a
good student with the gun would stop a
bad student with a gun there you go
there you go hard to argue with that
logic right
liz says this school shooting proves
again that heroes with guns are not the
answer the republican party offer no
viable solutions to prevent these issues
of course they don't
switzerland has one of the highest rates
of gun ownership in the world but very
little gun related crime in comparison
to the us last mass shooting there was
21 years ago radical changes needed to
alter the culture right the key
differences in switzerland are
uh much stricter licensing and a
drastically different cultural situation
where if i understand correctly and chat
can correct me actually maybe i should
even
gun ownership in switzerland
my understanding is people don't carry
the guns around with them
let's see here
so there's a number of different
yeah there's almost no permits to carry
and public concealed
swiss gun culture is is basically based
on yeah it's based on uh
it's not based on self-defense
everything is different in switzerland i
should research it more but everything
is different in switzerland
and that should that shouldn't surprise
us i think that that makes sense
thank you to bean product for the twitch
prime subscription your number 143
today
what's going on now second amendment
keep in mind that words endowment all
that money that you're seeing there 21
million dollars is still there
every year the ila harvest five percent
of that and they spend that to protect
somebody somewhere in some state in
america oh my god disgusting
david i want to say i love what you do
we live in a crazy country but i believe
the good will win thanks for inspiring
me to stay hopeful well i'm glad to hear
that vincent a lot of people in the
audience not feeling so hopeful lately
yeah um is there any
other coupon code available yeah
actually i realized i've been you i've
been mentioning the obama coupon code
but actually because trump is speaking
we have the coupon code sad trump which
is an even larger discount
if if people want to use it you're free
to use it that's it's absolutely allowed
no question about it
nomadcat says i just left the protest
people come out of the convention center
smiling and laughing lots of police
protecting them they don't care
what a vile situation
thanks to pd salinas for the twitch
prime subscription as a hype train kicks
off
also thanks to mappachin
mappachin for the twitch prime
subscription you're number 145 today i
really appreciate that
thank you again larry now we'll change
out the podium teleprompter oh god
so now they're going to be following us
on the trump rallies they have a kind of
a special protocol they do here uh as
far as the teleprompters and the podium
and all the good stuff so i'm gonna let
remember how trump criticized obama for
using a teleprompter and trump
actually not only he has a specific
teleprompter that he uses he can't use
just any teleprompter
thanks to sharpie diesel and blueberry
babe for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 146 and 147 today also want to
say thanks to kevin gouldy for gifting a
subscription on my website your number
148. listen guys when it comes to coupon
codes i want you to know
that you have choices
one option is as you can see on your
screen
a my pillow coupon code as you can see
the promo codes
give you significant discounts that's
one option the pillow codes
the other option are codes at
joinpakman.com
now i don't have to tell you which i
think is preferable you can be the judge
but if you want moccasins from pillow
you can use a coupon code on his website
or you can use the coupon code sad trump
or obama
at joinpakman.com that's really up to
you to decide
uh but i we are aware that this is not
your only choice
when it comes to coupon codes there are
many many choices of course
hey david this is kind of a message for
your viewers but i live in canada
probably
in one of the most right-wing places in
canada
and
we
do not have mass shootings like this
right it just doesn't happen i know i
don't know if
people are unwilling to like
look at other countries but
if this helps them at all
this just doesn't happen in canada and
otherwise we're not that different from
the us right you're just people yeah
what a nice uh i like that by the way
this doesn't happen here but we're not
that different it just we don't have
mass shootings
austin asks are guns classified as
machines would they be impacted by the
class action lawsuit that's a good
question imagine if mike pillow's
lawsuit
did something about guns we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines that's genuinely something to
look into
i don't know
uh
hey david love the coverage man uh my
wife and i are pretty upset about what's
been happening
she's been crying for a couple days now
uh i just want to say i'm super grateful
to be able to homeschool my own children
because i couldn't imagine sending them
to school right now with what's going on
all right thanks man
yeah i mean you know i i'm not like a
big
homeschooling guy in the sense of i mean
first of all in the united states
70 plus percent of homeschooling is done
because
right-wing christians don't want their
kids exposed to what happens in like
normal schools so they home school
so but that's more circumstantial
but also i do think it's tougher as far
as homeschooling goes to have kind of
like your typical socialization but i i
would understand in this case being like
i don't want
it's much less likely that there's a
school shooting at my home
a shooting at my home than that uh that
at a school i understand what parents
are saying
it's it's a crazy situation
here in switzerland you can't carry guns
in public unless you have a very good
reason like security and the heavier
guns you need more checks well said
well said
thanks to dj white rabbit for the twitch
prime subscription you're number 149 and
very excited to announce new member 150
today adam gingrich just signed up on
our website and his new member number
150
uh also want to say thanks to ernest
gray
who is new member 151 and a bunch of
gifts marjorie milner michael doctor
jason sickmeyer adam gingrich and adam
gingrich gifting another one puts us at
156.
really appreciate that let me put those
in queue so that people will get their
uh free memberships in america says
michael we have a problem that
encompasses poverty mental health and
access to guns
it's a lot of things no question
whatsoever
it is many many things
voicemails keep coming in
david pakman uh pennsylvania
i have a way we can uh help the students
in school shootings instead of giving
them computers and
calculators and
books and pencils we should give all
students
bulletproof vests there you go that
should help yeah no and what's
fascinating about that is there's people
who were like oh
a mask is psychologically
destroying my kid
let's solve this by
sending them to school with ballistic
blankets and
bulletproof backpacks oh but the mask
they it was so disturbing to them to
wear the mask it's uh
it's shocking
it's
shocking david so when do you think
they're going to start
doing gun safety and training for
education majors
you know so it's like oh i want to be a
math well that's the thing if you want
to teach you'll you'll have to i guess
now you've got to go to gun school
teacher but you have to have at least
three credit hours of gun safety and
knowing how to operate um an automatic
weapon and also knowing how to disable
someone who has one
all right david thanks yeah it's it's
completely and totally absurd
i mean there's no there's no other way
to put it it's it's an insane
proposition
uh
the background color at the podium is
orange trump will blend in and we won't
have to see his ugly mug
arming teacher seems like another good
way to drive competent educators out of
the public education system also machine
lawsuit might take down trump's special
teleprompter we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines the
stoneman douglas high school shooting
says liz also wasn't stopped by the
armed security guard on site no armed
heroes can be counted on
yeah i mean that's uh
that's a whole other issue we're dealing
with julia says i'm from denmark in
comparison there are fewer than 1500
homicides by gunshot in all of the eu
each year population 750 million think
about that it's disturbing to think
about
pierre says the good guy with a gun
thing is such a farce if i saw a guy
with a gun at a grocery store my initial
instinct wouldn't be oh good i feel safe
not to mention
if you've got a bad guy with a gun at
the grocery store
spotted by a good guy with a gun now
you've got two guys with guns when
police show up
they immediately have to know which one
is the good guy how do you know when
there's two people with guns pointed at
each other
it's uh
it just doesn't even pass the sniff test
thanks to julianne vared
as well as hannie hallen
hannie hallen
both of whom signed up on my website and
sonic mole chaser using the coupon code
obama
new members 157 158 and 159 also thanks
to adam gingrich gifting another
subscription and that's number 160 today
if gun control isn't the answer for
republicans says doug why haven't they
started locking doors and guarding
schools in their states it's always
their answer yet they haven't actually
done anything
for a bulletproof vest to stop a rifle
bullets it would have to be a hard plate
like steel my vest weighs 30 pounds the
soft vests won't help
that's that's that may be true i don't
even i haven't even gotten that far with
the idea
is pillow only going after compound
machines or even simple machines like
the pulley and inco inclined plane i
guess um the lawsuit inc uh also applies
to levers
or cantilevers as well can do is it
pronounced cantilever or cantilever
i think i've heard it both ways
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines yeah
uh
my uh
my espresso machine has been relegated
to legal hell thanks to the lawsuit
against all machines
regarding your good guy with a gun
versus bad guy with a gun comment this
happened in alabama a good guy with a
gun happened to be black was shot dead
oh i've not heard of that that's insane
if true
thanks to adam for the 50 super chat
conservatives want us to live in the
wild wild west yeah
here's wayne lapierre soon to introduce
uh president trump i i assume thanks to
parrot tri killer eric and mulcab t for
the twitch prime subscriptions puts us
at 163.
i really appreciate that
and
so many people supporting what has ended
up being a very long stream not
particularly wide but very very long
that's for sure
um in your opinion what took the police
so long to get to the classroom it's not
a matter of opinion there is a truth to
it
and
i don't have the full answer right now a
lot of things have been alleged
but i don't have the truth right now
my partner is a special ed teacher and
is leaving the classroom for remote
counseling in large part out of fear of
these events yeah
when good guys and bad guys all start
shooting at each other in a confined
space innocent people will be caught in
the crossfire of course
sir can we start asking rafael cruz and
others who's going to pay for it since
their proposals seemed to be hardening
doors
schools and kids as policy one proposal
was to take covet funds
and use them
pretty nuts
the republican policy on preventing gun
violence is literally the definition of
insanity more guns is not the answer and
never has been
of course it hasn't
liz is on fire with the super chats
today i have to say
uh let's see here
what else do we have oh voicemails
continue to pour in
a little bit of her you know with all
the top looking army teachers and arming
school administrators and school faculty
perhaps janitors and computer
programming teachers and chess teachers
i'm thinking why don't we just turn
schools across the country into
penetrable fortresses yeah with
reinforced concrete walls battlements
yeah iron gates barbed wire just make
them prisons you know
uh all right here's trump let's listen
to what he's gonna have to say
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god thanks to um
blueberry babe for one more gifted
subscription on twitch
also uh thanks to andrew avr drums for
gifting two more which we will give away
in the next couple of days putting us at
166.
is there anything more disgusting than
trump's presence here
well yeah
probably what he's about to say
thanks for rhinodactyl for the twitch
prime subscription appreciate that let's
go for 200. why not i think we're uh
we're a stone's throw away at least as
far as i can throw a stone
look at this guy
[Music]
yeah i'm sorry this is turning into a
cringe stream with the arrival of mango
mussolini for sure
uh the orange orifice says maybe we will
more commonly refer to him do you think
lowering the voting age to 16 would help
get gun control passed i'd have to think
about it i'd have to think about it
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a little awkward that now he's just
standing with the song playing i mean i
think maybe they should cut it i don't
know
[Music]
why aren't the teachers when we can give
good students guns that's not a bad idea
preston maybe that's the way to go about
it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm with everybody this is absolutely
vile
[Music]
we've endorsed jp right j.d mandela
wayne and thank you jason i'm honored to
be here in the great state of texas with
the wonderful patriots of the nra and
unlike some i didn't disappoint you by
not showing up wow
wow
yeah people were really clamoring for
greg abbott huh within 150 years the nra
has stood greg abbott's literally
dealing with a mass shooting dealing
with it terribly i should mention and
trump criticizes that he bailed
our sacred liberties as americans
and together we're going to be standing
strong and tall for many many years to
come
i really do appreciate this incredible
turnout i want to express my tremendous
gratitude to each and every one of you
yeah just real quick charlie makes a
good point if people need mercy bands
because this is too nauseating you can
ask the moderators and they'll give you
a mercy ban if you need it
i just heard him he made a wonderful
speech ted cruz senator
where are you thank you very much
ted thank you very much
[Applause]
great job
governor christie gnome is here christy
thank you
doing a fantastic job and north carolina
there's a hot politician
hey the hot politician lieutenant
governor mark robinson i don't know
where you are mark
i don't know where mark is but he is
fantastic we just had a very good day as
you know and a great day
as we gathered this week citizens across
this state and across this nation are
filled with
grief
in the wake of the heinous massacre of
rob elementary school
in uvalde
you value today all about that and what
a horrible horrible thing it was
to see it to watch it to hear about it
the terrible murder of 19 innocent
children and two adult teachers
with many badly injured was a savage
and barbaric atrocity that shocks the
conscience of every
single american so horrible
i want to ask for a brief moment of
silence as i read the names of these
beautiful people
all young
wonderful lives ahead of them
they're brave teachers whose lives this
is some of the worst pandering i've ever
seen of control
lunatic
so we'll start
alexandria
rubio oh this is risky
alitha
ramirez
[Music]
ann marie
garza
it's a literal gong show guadalupe
rodriguez
eliana
cruz
taurus
ellie
garcia
jacqueline cazares
jayla
nicole
silguero
oh my god
jace
love our nurse
oh god jose
flores
leila
salazar
trump can't read names swami vive
come on
[Music]
rodriguez
miranda mathis
nevaeh
bravo
[Music]
garcia
javier
lopez
two great and beautiful
brilliant teachers
eva
morales
irma
garcia the timing
[Music]
there was just like a random one there
and this is like when trump tried to say
the names of indian athletes
[Applause]
is an
incomprehensible loss
god literally not comprehensible stolen
from us by
a malice that no words can describe
sickness
the monster who committed this crime is
pure evil pure cruelty pure hatred
absolute pure hatred
and while those he slaughtered are now
with god in heaven he will be eternally
damned to burn
in the fires of hell oh my god
crowd wasn't sure if the hell line was
an applause line as we mourn for so many
beautiful victims i know that everyone
here joins me in praying for the
families who are suddenly missing
the brightest light in their lives
we see their agony we ask god
to ease their suffering and to heal
their pain and together we grieve side
by side i would respect him so much if
he was like hey you know what
it's not going to help
the same way
that the prayer didn't help to prevent
the shooting it's not going to help
we've actually got to do something set
on the horrible day of tragedy we
witnessed
a now familiar parade of cynical
politicians seeking to exploit the tears
of sobbing families
to increase their own power and take
away our constitutional rights
every time a disturbed or demented
person commits such a hideous crime
there's always a grotesque effort
by some in our society to use the
suffering of others
to advance their own extreme political
agenda
like trump even more repulsive is their
rush to
shift blame away from the villains who
commit acts of mass violence here we go
and to place that blame onto the
shoulders of millions of peaceful
law-abiding
citizens who belong to organizations
such as our wonderful nra
when joe biden blamed the gun lobby he
was talking about americans like you
and along with countless other democrats
this week he was
shamefully suggesting that republicans
are somehow okay with letting school
shootings
happen they're not okay with it
this rhetoric is highly divisive and
dangerous and most importantly it's
wrong
it has no place in our politics
as always in the wake of these tragedies
the various gun control policies being
pushed
by the left would have done nothing to
prevent the horror that took place
absolutely nothing untrue
four or five of my ten proposals would
have directly impacted what happened
three four days ago
by a contagion of school shootings
carried out by
deeply evil violent and mentally
disturbed
young men
well we
don't yet know enough about this week's
killing we know there are many
things we must do
we need to drastically change our
approach to mental health
there are always so many warning signs
almost all of these
disfigured minds share the same
profile
when people see something whether on
social media or in school
they need to say something
teachers parents school officials and
community members need to be
recognizing and addressing these alarm
bells promptly
and very very aggressively
and our school
discipline systems
instead of making
excuses and continually turning a blind
eye need to confront bad behavior
head-on and quickly
[Applause]
and clearly we need to make it far
easier to confine the violent and
mentally deranged into mental
institutions
we have also
very importantly
got to deal with the problem of broken
families because no law can cure the
effects of a broken home
there is no substitute for a strong mom
and a great dad
is that homophobic you guys think
like is he being subtly homophobic with
that
but while we work to address these deep
complicated issues and deal with this
scourge
score all of us unite republican and
democrat in every state and at every
level government to finally harden our
schools and protect our children
[Applause]
what we need now is a top to bottom
security overhaul at schools all across
our country
[Applause]
every building should have a single
point of entry
so they've just decided this is our
talking point this time around fencing
metal detectors and the use of new
technology to make sure that no
unauthorized individual can ever enter
the school and or with a weapon
[Applause]
no one should ever be able to get
anywhere near a classroom until they
have been checked scanned screened and
fully approved all right so yeah just
like a prison or airport yeah
so important
in addition classroom doors should be
hardened to make them lockable from the
inside and closed to intruders
from the outside
and above all
from this day forward every school in
america should have a police officer or
an armed resource officer on duty at all
times more guns guys
[Applause]
moreover at every police department in
america we need a rigorous training on
active shooter protocols to immediately
locate and eliminate the target
took too long
and we need to expand funding recruiting
and training for police departments
nationwide
this is not a matter of money this is a
matter of will
if the united states has 40 billion
dollars to send to ukraine we should be
able to do whatever it takes to keep our
children
safe at home
there you go yeah we should i mean just
let putin take whatever he wants i guess
huh just throwing that in there
that's true
we spent trillions in iraq
trillions in afghanistan we got nothing
before we nation build the rest of the
world we should be building safe schools
for our own children
in our own nation right
[Applause]
year alone biden and congressional
democrats sent 122 billion dollars in
so-called coveted relief funds to k-12
schools even while they were keeping
many of our
schools totally shut down
no doubt severely worsening the mental
health challenge of many youth i mean
many of these
young people
really
suffered very greatly they became very
ill they may have been ill to start but
they became very very ill
congress should vote immediately to take
back every penny of unused covert relief
money
take it back from the states and use
that money to quickly establish
impenetrable security at every school
all across our land this the vocabulary
in this speech is way too complicated
for trump
as many have noted inner city schools
rarely have these kinds of mass
shootings i didn't know that until just
recently
think of that they rarely have this
problem despite being located in very
tough neighborhoods in many cases where
there's tremendous levels of high crime
and violence they're much more dangerous
outside the school than inside the
reason is that for decades inner city
schools have had much stronger security
measures in place in the school itself
that's only true very anecdotally and
yes armed guards they had guns
armed guards
whatever our differences may be on other
issues what on earth is stopping
democrats from immediately passing
measures to ramp up school security
this school had an armed guard i guess
the guy was like
away at the time
how many more tragedies will it take
until they agree to set aside their far
left political agenda and do what
is really needed and what actually works
this is not about virtue
cycling and signing this is about
blaming your enemies no we don't want to
they put virtue signaling on his
prompter he doesn't know what it is he
called it virtue cycling you want to do
surely we can all agree it's not roller
skating or skateboarding either
the softest target our school should be
the single
hardest target in our country
[Applause]
and that's why as part of a
comprehensive school safety plan it's
time to finally allow highly trained
teachers to safely and discreetly
concealed
carry and let them conceal
[Applause]
disastrous idea
and again they have to be able to handle
it they have to be highly trained all of
those things but let them do that it
would be so
much better and so much more effective
even from a cost standpoint
because there is no sign more inviting
to a
mass killer than a sign that declares a
gun free zone
most dangerous place
i know it sounds good and it really does
doesn't sound wonderful but it's not
and statistically it's a total disaster
gun-free zone they look at that sign and
they say that's where i'm going
we cannot have that because if somebody
goes into
that building
all of those innocent people
will be taken out we'll be killed you
really i get the sense that trump
doesn't even believe any of this stuff
he's just writing what reading what's
been written for him the way to stop a
bad guy with a gun
is a good guy with a gun have you ever
heard that no you've never heard that
[Applause]
and in the absence of a member of law
enforcement there is no one you would
rather have nearby
when a crisis strikes than an armed
expertly trained member of the nra
[Applause]
remember that most gun owners are not
nra members
let's not pretend that those on the left
are just talking about limiting one
class of gun or one category of
ammunition you know they're not doing
that
we all know they want
total gun
confiscation
know that
this would be a first step
once they get the first step they'll
take the second step the third the
fourth and then
you'll have a whole different
look at the second
amendment which is by the way totally
under siege
but we stopped it for four years we
stopped
but even if every decent and honest
american gave up their guns the
criminals would never give up theirs and
they never will they're never going to
give up theirs they would wreak havoc
like never before in our country
the fact is there will always be sick
and
demonic souls who wish to harm the
innocent and see malice
triumph over good
gonna have that
but the existence of evil in our world
is not a reason to disarm law abiding
citizens who know how to use their
weapon and can protect a lot of people
the existence of evil is one of the very
best reasons to arm law
abiding citizens
[Applause]
trump always sort of seems to have only
a very loose relationship with the
speech he's reading but he seems
particularly disconnected from what he's
reading here all american men and women
with the knowledge and tools they need
to defend themselves their families and
their communities have to defend their
communities and their families
every single year the nra's
125 000 certified instructors these are
highly trained
very very capable people they train an
incredible one million americans to be
safe for gun owners ready to act when
the situation calls incredible job
and every day that training is
protecting the vulnerable and
safeguarding the innocent
an estimated 500 000 to 2.5 million
americans each year use a firearm in
self-defense the vast majority without
ever even having to fire a shot
often times they know you have it and
they say no thank you we're not gonna
we're not gonna mess with her
in addition according to newly released
data from the fbi last year there were
not one not two not three but four
active shooters who were taken out
by an armed civilian bravely exercising
their second amendment rights four wow
and how many mass shootings were there
that is what the second amendment is all
about
we're honored to be joined today by a
true texas hero
the sunday after christmas in 2019
veteran firearms instructor jack wilson
was attending services at the west
freeway church of christ outside
of fort worth
he saw a strange man enter the church
and after that jack never took his eyes
off him would not leave him he knew
something was wrong
right up until the man approached the
person serving communion
and pulled out a gun
thankfully after texas passed a law
allowing concealed carry
in places of worship jack had
volunteered to lead his church's
citizens there were 693 mass shootings
last year
and they have these four instances wow
pulled out their firearms very quickly
very professionally the shooter gunned
down jack's team member and then turned
and killed the man serving holy
communion
amid the chaos jack had only
an instant to take aim
he saw his chance and took out the
shooter
with a single perfect shot
incredible
this is the worst of the worst of
everything
in the world
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
stay right here
[Applause]
stay right there jack
[Applause]
thanks to jack sharp eye and swift
action the shooter was down within six
seconds out
from pulling his gun think of that six
seconds
and with more than 240 worshipers in the
church which perhaps all would be gone
right now jack had saved the lives of an
old really an untold number of innocent
people that he knew very well and he
loved
jack we want to thank you for a job well
done we salute you a true professional a
really great man jack say a few words
yeah
okay
dear god
[Applause]
thank each and every one of you again
thank you president trump and you're
still my president
it's it's a cult yup
wow what a sick event huh
what i did that day
was not for my glory
it was to save
countless friends and family
in that setting
i hope you're never put in that position
but understand if you are put in that
position you have to make that decision
to do what is right
not what somebody says well you
shouldn't do that no
i did not kill a human being that day i
took out evil
[Applause]
wow this this is this is this is worse
than even i expected happened
in uvalde this week
that was evil
we have to deal with evil at all levels
you have to stand up
and be prepared to protect also if the
guy didn't have his rifles nothing would
have happened in this country
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much jack as jack's story
reminds us defending our second
amendment is about defending law order
and life we know that
as law and order conservatives we have
no higher goal than to reduce violent
crime by the greatest degree you're at
an event where the highest goal is
selling guns what is required
over the past two years our nation has
paid a
horrifically bloody price for the
democrats to fund the police rhetoric
and their weak on crime
policies we have paid a big price
in every city where the left attacked
the police slashing funding
or hired radical prosecutors violent
crime has skyrocketed
last year 12 major cities hit all-time
highs this is
the history of our country all-time
highs
in record
homicides
and this year is looking far far worse
not even close
in democrat-run sacramento last year a
man with a
long criminal history was released from
jail on zero bail and wish
wish that he
would never have been put in jail that
was his wish
weeks later he broke into an innocent
woman's home sexually assaulted her
murdered her
killed her two dogs and set her house on
fire
this past february in new york another
horrible person with at least six prior
arrests was released without bail before
going on a
stalking tour
i'm glad they're not making any of this
stuff political went into her apartment
stabbing her to death and leaving her
body
in the bathtub
and recently in philadelphia thug
murdered an innocent man walking his dog
two weeks after being released
on armed kidnapping and assault charges
where he badly badly
hurt a number of people
the very same democrat politicians who
stoked riots over a single police
involved killing two years just one it
was just one killing guys they only
killed george floyd come on policies
but we must not be we cannot let that
happen
big city mayors like lori lightfoot
chicago
muriel bowser in washington
jim kenney in philadelphia watch the
slaughter hey for this person saying why
am i not showing the protest we
literally did two hours of the protests
and now we're doing the trump speech
proper approach to
policing prosecuting and jailing
we could cut violent crime in our major
cities by much more than half and it
would take place almost
immediately
under the greatest mayor in the history
of new york rudy giuliani
they cut violent crime by 58 percent
imagine cheering for giuliani in 2022
virtue recycling
a few
years
and then it got better than that
and under our own administration we
significantly reduced violent crime
three years in a row
we resurrected project safe
neighborhoods bringing together
prosecutors police sheriffs citizen
groups to
get dangerous felons off the streets and
off
the streets rapidly
we funded 200 new violent crime
prosecutors with operation legend
we searched hundreds and hundreds of
federal law enforcement officers to
democrat-run cities that you've heard so
many horrible things about
to put violent defenders behind bars
where they belong when they started
knocking down statues in washington d.c
and other locations
i watched this in amazement
lincoln
jefferson washington knocking them down
and i immediately signed an executive
order which stated that anybody
even
lightly defaces a federal monument or
statue will get a minimum of 10 years in
prison 10 years
and immediately upon signing it
everything stopped do you ever notice
that it all stopped there was nothing
didn't happen
amazing isn't it i felt i had a
political and moral obligation to allow
democrat
mayors and governors to run their cities
and states when it came to crime and
riots and
even horrible violence
in my own mind i was allowing the
democrats to show how they would handle
the situation
and when it got out of control i got
involved i got a government
energized i called the national guard
and federal law enforcement and we saved
the cities of
minneapolis kenosha seattle chicago
and even portland
doing some very very bad times in those
places
but then they wander back
to the past
but if i ever do it again namely run for
president and win i would no longer feel
obligated to do it that way right i
would crack down on violent crime like
never before
this time he would do it
which is the way i would have liked to
have done it
the first time but in a certain way
i'm glad i didn't
the easiest simplest most
straightforward thing we can do to save
thousands of american lives from
violence
is to hire more police arrest more
violent criminals give them speedy
trials and get them into jail
that one didn't include guns so the
crowd wasn't as big on it seeing what
the democrats do when they're left to
run the cities
so now
it has to be done right
over time that will save tens of
thousands of lives and billions and
billions of
dollars never forget the same people
that are lecturing us about
gun confiscation are the ones who are
also taking cops off the street and
letting criminals out of jail knowing
that it will get tens of thousands
of americans killed and killed rather
quickly unfortunately
you really wonder do the democrats
even care
now the radical left democrats are
continuing to push
to abolish cash bail
and to strip our police officers of
their
qualified immunity
just this week the biden administration
announced new policies threatening to
hold law enforcement officers liable
not only for their misconduct but even
for the misconduct of other officers a
totally destructive policy that will
only make
our communities less safe
what officer is going to get involved if
they think they can lose everything
their family their pension everything
it's crazy what's going on not even
thinkable
if democrats truly care about stopping
the bloodshed in america
the biden administration's war on police
must end and it must end right now
we will no longer defund
it's weird to make that case when the
police seem to have so brutally bungled
what happened earlier this week in texas
we will no longer
i knew it had to happen
who is that man stand up please because
what does that do
had to happen
we will no longer defund the police and
we will no longer even mention the
funding of the police we will never
mention it again oh they said fbi
great american heroes
and
if allowed to do their job they will do
it like nobody else can all of those
crime statistics will be cut
so in such a big way you'll be so proud
you'll be so proud to be an american
when you see in chicago when you see in
chicago 80 people shot
sometimes in a weekend
and many people dying that's a war zone
when you see what's happening at other
cities it's just incredible so
you'll be proud to be in trump's getting
to the dripping wet portion of the
speech we should pass legislation
strengthening qualified immunity for our
police officers we have to do that
[Applause]
who would ever take a job without that
think of it who would ever take a job
ruin your life have one bad
story that may be made up because a lot
of the stories are made up one bad made
up song you killed one person as a cop
they never let you be a cop again that's
not fair protect
us
and we must do our duty to protect them
have to do it
earlier this week the law enforcement
officer who stopped the texas shooters
rampage was reportedly a member of the
group joe biden
has most viciously betrayed wait a
second are they going to pretend the
police response was good on tuesday
brave
[Applause]
every day our amazing border patrol
agents and ice officers are risking
their lives to keep our
communities safe and when we regain
control of congress we must do that
please remember that
we can stop
socialism and communism at one time
oh my god we will once again give these
great patriots the authority the
resources and the respect
they need and dearly deserve they need
this they have to have it but we need it
we need more than they do
there can be no doubt that the crime
crisis is fueled in part by the
biden border crisis numbers of people
coming in at levels that nobody's ever
seen before probably that no country has
ever seen before
when i left office we handed the new
administration
the most secure by far border
in the history of the united states
we ended catch and release
we ended asylum fraud we struck historic
agreements with mexico
stay in mexico is that a nice sounding
agreement there to stay in mexico mexico
i didn't immediately terminated stay in
mexico along with pipelines and every
other thing and now congratulations
gasoline just hit in a lot of places
today
9.25
is that true that can't be true
we deported illegal alien gang members
by the thousands and we built nearly 500
miles of
great beautiful new border wall the
exact same specifications that the
border patrol gave us we got it built
and then we started building more we're
going to add another 200 we were almost
finished with that
and then lo and behold they
came in with a very bad election very
bad
to put it wildly
they came in with a bad election and
they stopped building the border wall
and when texas went to them and wanted
to use the fencing that was already
bought and paid for and sitting there
waiting it's kind of seeming like the
nra is more than just a gun rights
organization it seems that their members
are big lie supporters conspiracy
theorists it it basically seems like
part of the trump cult nightmare of all
time and
you are paying a very high price for
that right here in texas you're paying a
very high price
we're the greatest border the most
secure border in this country
in our country's history
under biden it's always america last one
globalist sellout after another it's
america last it's even reported that the
biden administration is considering
putting u.n bureaucrats in charge of
your second amendment rights
[Applause]
[Music]
just like i'm sure that most of you
haven't heard this but you know who's i
terminated the iran nuclear deal because
it was a disaster they want to go back
into it you know who's negotiating for
us
russia and china
how's that going to work out you think
that's good this is super relevant to
the nra huh imagine russia and china
saying do you believe this he wants us
to negotiate the deal for him
ah this is a sad day this is one of the
saddest times for our country that i've
ever seen yeah he's not even talking
about the shooting i re-enter the
ridiculous u.n arms trade treaty and
pursuing a u.n ban on
lead ammunition you know that because
it's not environmentally friendly
[Applause]
is there a substitute for lead you
people are better at this than me
wayne is there so where's jason is there
a substitute they want to get rid of
lead because it's environmentally
unfriendly
the last time i appeared at this nra
leadership forum i stood before you and
i proudly signed a document revoking
america's signature
from the globalist u.n disaster
what
under my leadership we never surrenders
american sovereignty we would never
surrender american sovereignty and we
always
put
america first
i remember in the early weeks of the
biden administration globalist
biden said
we're not going to stand for america
first
now you know even if you didn't agree
with our policy you can't say that
it is a great name isn't it america
first the only thing better might be
ultra mega they gave us a great day
but compare that all of the things we
talk about we see we feel
and many of the things we don't talk
about compare that with how great
america was just two years ago right
think of it there was no inflation
things were so great then remember what
was going on two weeks two years ago it
would never ever have happened would
have never happened
i spoke to putin about it would it never
ever happened he knew the consequences
he would have never done it
in fact he didn't do it sleepy eyes
chucked out on
meet the fake press
you ever hear meet the fake press or to
face the nation those shows
ladies and gentlemen it's president
donald trump on deface the nation
he seems like he's on downers he shows
but he was saying
to blinket i believe he said uh how come
this never happened with trump don't
forget georgia
was given up by bush hate to say it
georgia was given up by bush crimea was
given up by
obama and biden obama his name in that
if you don't mind
nothing was given up by trump
and then all of ukraine essentially
was given up by biden because what do
they have left you know with all the
shooting all the rockets every city is
being leveled what are they going to
have
there's no win here for anybody
there's no win this should have never
been allowed to start it would have 100
percent never
started
if we didn't have a rigged election
would have this is genuinely bonkers
we had
1.87 per gallon gasoline think of that
1.87
energy independence and soon we were
going to have energy dominance we were
going to be
we were going to be bigger than russia
and saudi arabia combined to buy a lot
we're on the way going to be very very
soon we were leaving afghanistan with
dignity and strength not surrender death
and leaving 85 billion dollars worth of
beautiful brand new
equipment
giving it to the enemy
you know they're a tremendous arms
dealer right now they sell they're
selling mostly because how much do they
need they don't need that
so they're selling it they're the
biggest arms dealer in many ways i
understand on many of the charts they're
number one
think of it 85 billion dollars worth of
brand new stuff helicopters planes
goggles imagine talking to the nra about
this whole thing
we had completely i believe that was the
lowest point in the history of our
country the way we got i was the one
that got it down to two thousand
soldiers but we were going to keep
bagram bagram is this great air base
that was built many years ago at a cost
of billions and billions but we weren't
keeping it for afghanistan we're keeping
it because it's one hour away from where
china makes their nuclear weapons
now he left and one night everybody was
gone they left the lights on think of it
the lights were all left on the dogs
were left behind by the way for those
people like dogs
the noise causes cancer you know that
they don't like dogs
they don't like them at all but think of
it just think of it
billions and billions of dollars it took
to build it years ago
and now china is going to occupy it very
shortly in china already china we had a
completely rebuilt military with the
addition of space force first time in 17
years that that's happened after
air force
the air force was the last and now we
have space floors
and that's going to prove to be a very
important
group of people and that's exactly what
it's going to be you know they smiled
when they saw it they came in you saw
that
their guns don't work in space don't
talk to the nra about space force they
don't care you saw that right
and she said space force and she started
laughing
and the military just excoriated her
there was nothing funny about it and now
everybody's admitting was so important
because russia and china were
way ahead of us in space but they're not
anymore
we had the biggest tax cuts and
regulation cuts ever the history of our
country
and we had historic job numbers 164
million people
and so much more we did so much more
even right to try you know what that is
you're terminally ill we gave a person
the right to try new
techniques new things new medicines and
many many people are
now alive and well because of right to
try and they didn't have to go to asia
they didn't have to go to europe all
over the world or go home if they had no
money in asia right to try and they've
been trying to get it for 56 years
and we got it done
passed actually we got it passed not as
easy as you think
sounds easy but
the drug companies didn't want it
because they didn't want it on their
record the country didn't want it
because they didn't want to get sued
many different things we got everybody
to sign waivers and
we have it now and we're saving
thousands of lives it's incredible
what's happened and what it is doing is
telling the drug companies frankly up
front and personal whether or not
something works right
so it's
i might even bail on this i mean it's
just it's going nowhere the earliest
endorsement in the entire history
of the nra
i tell you what that was a very
important thing
[Applause]
what was he talking about it was like
getting into a great college you say boy
that feels good
everybody wanted it don't forget we had
a total of 18 people running
and uh
your leadership and which are very much
appreciated big massive everybody else
they uh they said we really like trump
and that was before we were
very much enmeshed in the campaign
people weren't sure how that was going
to work out but i can tell you it worked
out very well for the nra so we
appreciate it we appreciated the
endorsement very much
okay
and we got it the second time too we got
12 million more votes the second time
how about that somebody said how did you
do the second time compared to the first
one we did much better the second time
which is true
there was record turnout both candidates
got a lot of votes in time that we did
the first but we got
we got two of them and
uh if we do this again we hope we're
gonna get a third
okay then i can tell you is that legal
thank you thank you to the leadership
president
and as your president i was proud to be
the best friend that law abiding gun
owners have
ever had in the white house and we've
been giving that
given that credential over four
incredible years we appointed nearly 300
federal judges to interpret the laws of
the constitution as written including
three great new supreme court justices
when the radical democrats tried to use
covet to shut down gun stores during the
pandemic even as left-wing rioters
burned down cities
i designated gun and ammunition
retailers as critical infrastructure
kept those stores open there you go
[Applause]
i cancel the obama administration's
exploitation of social security data to
deny americans their gun rights without
due process of law
which was a big deal at the time we
ended obama's enormous abuse of power
known as operation choke point under
which government bureaucrats pressured
banks to cut off services to firearms
and the firearms industry
and we are optimistic that in the weeks
to come the supreme court will issue
landmark rulings affirming that your
rights to self-defense does not end when
you step outside of your front door
and i think very importantly as
president i stood up for america's
hunters and fishers and sportsmen like
no administration since teddy roosevelt
he was good also i will say
we expanded access to 1.4 million acres
of public lands for hunting sportsmen
come on the american people their land
back it was taken away by government and
we stopped the obama era regulatory
assaults on hunting trapping ammunition
abolishing gear
everyone here today is united by one
incredibly powerful bond we're all
citizens of the united states of america
the greatest country in the history of
the world
but we're not
but we're not so great anymore we're
going to make it great we're going to
make it greater than ever again
greater than ever again right now
right now we're not respected by
other parts of the world or leaders of
the world we're not remember that that's
completely untrue respect for the united
states around the world has increased
since trump left and joe biden came in
you can disagree with what they've done
but that's what is the truth the head of
the taliban
and some of the fake news that is here
today with us pleasure
why is he speaking to the taliban why
will he mention aberdeen yes jesse james
why do you rob banks he said because
that's where the money is right
why do i speak to the taliban and i did
i spoke to abdul who's still the leader
of the taliban
a very nice way don't ever kill any of
our people 18 months we went 18 months
we went
without one american soldier being
killed until that tragic tragic day
and i think that's actually what
convinced putin to go into
ukraine when he saw what was happening
when he saw the gross incompetence of
what took place during that short period
of time in afghanistan i think that's
when he decided to
go in but he would have never done it
it's our citizenship that protects our
birthright our freedoms that belong to
every american of every race religion
color and creed no matter who we are or
what our background in america is we
have the right
to freedom of speech
we have the right to freedom of assembly
freedom of association free and fair
elections and we have the right to very
very strong and powerful borders
i used to say
without borders we don't have a country
now i say without borders and proper
elections we don't have a country sure
we have a right to religious liberty we
have a right to
the full fair and impartial rule of law
but also we can never forget that we
have a right to our second amendment
which is under siege
but we will prevail we will prevail
as our bill of rights says in those
clear and immortal words the right of
the people to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed
[Applause]
we've endorsed jp right
in times of hardship crisis and turmoil
these core american freedoms have always
been attacked by those who wish to turn
citizens into subjects and take more
power for themselves but thankfully our
nation has always been blessed with
americans like you you're incredible
americans in this room
patriots who know that our rights are
given up
if we let somebody do
the wrong thing it's very simple it's
very precious
but we live by the hand of almighty god
and that no government can ever
be taken away from us
more than 150 years ago the nra was born
out of the idea that ordinary citizens
should be prepared to
defend these incredible liberties and
throughout the generations that is
exactly what americans have done
over the decades tens of millions of
people moms and dads
grandfathers and grandmothers farmers
and factory workers nurses and teachers
soldiers and lawmen have been proud cad
and you know this they have been so
proud i see it all the time people show
me their card here it is they've been
very proud card carrying members of the
nra sir i have my nra card i say okay
sure
are you sorry sir sure you got a lot of
people out there he has his trump card
thank you very much
you got a lot of people out there with
that card it's very important and during
that time
you've been led by a legion of american
legends from
great general
ambrose burnside who you know to the
great american hero ulysses s grant and
of course
that fearless patriot the
down throughout history time and time
again hard-working citizens like you
have answered the call to save this is
the stupidest speech now together we are
going to save american freedom once
again we have no choice we're gonna have
to do it again save it again because
right now we don't have american freedom
we are going to preserve our heritage we
are going to defend our rights we are
going to protect our communities protect
our schools and protect our precious
children we are going to secure
our liberties
for ourselves and for every future
generation
in 2022 we are going to vote for tough
on crime pro-second amendment candidates
in record numbers get out and vote
make sure the voting's honest by the way
together we're going to take back the
house we're going to take back the
senate and in 2024 we are going to take
back that great and you know it's not
it's not a guarantee that every nra
member is a republican i mean it's a
right-leaning organization but it's a
weird speech too for that reason
and then we're going to make america
safer freer richer stronger prouder and
greater
than ever before
to the incredible patriots people of
texas
god bless you and god bless america
thank you very much great honor thank
you
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is
[Music]
in all seriousness imagine going to
speak to trump uh maybe i'll just do one
more tweet
uh
trump just finished speaking at the nra
three days after the worst mass shooting
since
since sandy
hook and he danced to music at the
conclusion
of his speech
what a what a sickening display in
absolutely every way
man
yeah
well it's pretty freaking bad guys i'm
not gonna lie it is completely
weaponized i i i
i don't even have a comment i'm gonna
take the weekend to think about the
comment that i'm gonna make when we get
back to the show after memorial day
it's not good
it's not good exactly
thanks to everybody who supported the
stream in all seriousness very very much
appreciate that yeah i know
i saw sean spicer has like six chins now
i i can't do anything about that i don't
even have anything to say about it it's
we can't even deal with that i can't
even engage with that at this point all
right everybody we'll see you very soon
thank you that's the end for today
you